Shure:  你给的是那个镜像啊
Shure: You gave him the mirror image.
Shure:  你被这种人
Shure: You got played by this kind of person.
Nicous: 已经红了不知道
Nicous: He's already red, you know.
Nicous: 她追个三星的还隔这恶心人什么人
Nicous: She's chasing a three-star and still annoying people, what kind of person...
Katrina:  来吗修硕
Katrina: Coming, Shure?
俢硕：来了
Shure: Coming.
Tasha: 就差几个立场足
Tasha: Just a few more positions.
Katrina:  就往就往这上面放你想要压的就行
Katrina: Just place it here, you can press what you want.
Shure:  我想压压一个哎
Shure: I want to press one, hey.
Katrina:  可以先放薄的花瓣可以
Katrina: You can put the thin petals first.
Tasha: 一个两个还差一个立场足
Tasha: One, two, just one more position.
Tasha: 还差一个无敌啊
Tasha: Just one more invincible.
Katrina:  这个我感觉也这样吧
Katrina: I think this one too.
Katrina:  就这样摆着就行
Katrina: Just place it like this.
Tasha: 哈哈他他打不过我
Tasha: Haha, he can't beat me.
俢硕：拿一个有设计感一点的
Shure: Get one with some design sense.
Tasha: 然后他还可以再跟我玩
Tasha: Then he can keep playing with me.
Katrina: 非常修身养性
Katrina: Very calming.
Katrina:  你那里有几片啊Lucy就是木板
Katrina: How many pieces do you have, Lucia, like wood boards?
Lucia: 嗯我下下面那个是4片
Lucia: Hmm, the bottom one has four pieces.
Lucia: 不过是小的
Lucia: But they're small.
Lucia: 上面只有
Lucia: There's only
Tasha: 嗯是的
Tasha: Yeah, that's right.
Lucia: 我打算先放两个
Lucia: I plan to put two first.
Katrina:  我说因为木板啊
Katrina: I said because of the plank...
Lucia: 木板木板只有一个
Lucia: There's only one plank.
Tasha: 嗯乌迪尔
Tasha: Yeah, Udyr.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Nicous: ok  ok
Nicous: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 不过纸有很多
Lucia: But there's a lot of paper.
Nicous: 主角差一个
Nicous: The main character is missing one.
Katrina:  还有一个木板呢哦在这
Katrina: There's another plank... oh, here it is.
Tasha: 123 嗯
Tasha: One, two, three, hmm.
Tasha: 内脏桌也差一个
Tasha: The organ table is missing one too.
Shure:  然后这个可以摘是吗
Shure: Then can we pick this?
Katrina:  可以啊但感觉这叶子不是很好看
Katrina: Yeah, but I feel the leaves aren't very pretty.
Nicous: 卖了卖了卖了卖了
Nicous: Sell it, sell it, sell it.
Tasha: 卖谁啊
Tasha: Sell to who?
Katrina: 这种小花就可以直接摘
Katrina: You can just pick these small flowers directly.
Jake: 怎么还
Jake: How come...
Tasha: 谁卖谁啊
Tasha: Who's selling to who?
Jake: 还你是挂了吗
Jake: Are you lagging?
Katrina:  我还有一个东西要做
Katrina: I still have one more thing to do.
Tasha: 卖谁啊
Tasha: Sell to who?
Katrina: 我天呐
Katrina: Oh my gosh.
Katrina:  这辈子没干过活这么多手工活
Katrina: I've never done this much handcraft work in my life.
Katrina:  从小幼儿园的时候上手工课就不会做
Katrina: Ever since kindergarten, I was bad at handcraft class.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  就给糖给别人让别人做
Katrina: I'd give candy to others to make them do it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 从小就会
Katrina: Since I was little.
Katrina:  这种雇佣劳动力
Katrina: Always hiring labor.
Tasha: 嗯应该不会吧
Tasha: Hmm, probably not.
Katrina:  然后就很多年没有做过手了
Katrina: And then I haven't done it for years.
Shure:  这压出来是一整张是吗
Shure: This presses out a whole sheet, right?
Katrina:  没有压出来
Katrina: It didn't press out.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: It's like...
Lucia: 像这样
Lucia: Like this.
Lucia: 就是它会变成一个一个干
Lucia: It turns into pieces.
俢硕：啊 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure:  嗨
Shure: Hi.
Tasha: 它启动是慢
Tasha: 因为我带的装备不对
Shure:  我以为是构成一幅画呢
Tasha: 不是带了个偷吗
Katrina:  那那这些棒干了以后
Shure: 那它这些棒
Katrina:  再自己拼拼成一副画
俢硕：棒有什么用呢
Katrina:  当然你也可以发挥你的创造力
Katrina:  然后之后你就拿它干
Katrina:  了以后它颜色也保存了
Katrina:  你就拿胶水粘那种明信片啊
Nicous: 他是不是在砍你啊
Katrina:  或者什么都可以
Katrina:  或者夹玻璃片
Tasha: 他还有这种本领
Tasha: 他怎么可能会有这种
Nicous: 卖了 卖乌迪尔
Tasha: 卖谁
Nicous: 卖乌迪尔
Nicous: 服 冲
Shure:  我试试来然后呢
Shure: Let me try, then what?
Katrina:  没然后了
Katrina: There's no "then what".
Katrina:  就把你压扁就行
Katrina: Just press it down.
Katrina:  不是你多放点呗
Katrina: Or you could add more.
Shure:  什么叫多放一点
Shure: What do you mean by "add more"?
Tasha: 这就是你的磁塔
Tasha: This is your magnetic tower.
Jake:一陀大便
Jake: A pile of poop.
俢硕：啊都可以利用
Shure: Oh, we can use all of it.
Tasha: 这就是你的磁塔Shure:
Tasha: This is your magnetic tower, Shure.
Shure:  那这些棒也要压一下吗
Shure: Do we have to press these sticks too?
Tasha: 都受不了了
Tasha: I can't take it anymore.
Katrina:  我觉得第一层先压薄的吧
Katrina: I think we should press the thin layer first.
Katrina:  这个放厚点
Katrina: Make this one thicker.
Katrina:  先压薄的就一片一片摆上去
Katrina: Press the thin layer first, put it piece by piece.
Shure: 哦 好
Shure: Oh, alright.
Tasha: 盖上一些小罐子我靠
Tasha: Cover it with some small jars, oh my god.
Tasha: 这就是你的
Tasha: This is your...
Nicous: 笑死我了他有9个槽爪录下来了
Nicous: This is hilarious, he's got 9 slots recorded.
Nicous: 一会他就学会了
Nicous: He'll learn it in a bit.
Nicous: 一会要卖乌迪尔了别着急
Nicous: We'll be selling Udyr soon, no rush.
Tasha: 要卖力曾主
Tasha: We need to sell Li Zeng Zhu.
Nicous: 要卖力曾主
Nicous: We need to sell Li Zeng Zhu.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Katrina:  你特别有一种
Katrina: You really look like
Katrina:  被妈妈送过去上那种兴趣班的
Katrina: A kid whose mom sends them to those hobby classes.
Katrina:  那种小孩
Katrina: That kind of kid.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  坐着乖乖的
Katrina: Sitting there obediently.
Katrina:  你妈
Katrina: Your mom.
俢硕：毫无感情是吧
Shure: Completely emotionless, right?
Katrina:  对毫无感情
Katrina: Yeah, completely emotionless.
Katrina:  等你妈来接你回家的
Katrina: Waiting for your mom to pick you up.
Katrina:  我是那老师监督
Katrina: I'm the teacher supervising.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then?
Shure:  铺完了然后呢
Shure: After spreading it out, then what?
Katrina:  铺完了
Katrina: After spreading it out.
Katrina:  然后就没有然后了
Katrina: Then there's nothing more.
Katrina:  然后就把板子盖上
Katrina: Then you just cover it up.
Katrina:  就
Katrina: Just...
Shure: 怎么怎么盖这个东西
Shure: How do you cover this thing?
Katrina:  我看看再放一点
Katrina: Let me see, add a bit more.
Katrina:  放满充分利用
Katrina: Fill it up, make full use of it.
Shure:  好好的轩老师
Shure: Good job, Teacher Xuan.
Katrina:  怎么都叫我轩老师
Katrina: Why does everyone call me Teacher Xuan?
Shure:  又忘了你姓啥了
Shure: Forgot your surname again.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure:  没有没有记着呢记着呢
Shure: No, no, I remember, I remember.
Shure:  节目效果懂吗
Shure: It's for the show effect, you know?
Katrina:  懂懂懂
Katrina: Got it, got it.
Katrina:  主要是之前那男生也叫我轩老师啊
Katrina: Mainly because that guy before also called me Teacher Xuan.
Shure:  完了勾起你不好意思回忆了是吗
Shure: So it brought back some awkward memories, huh?
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
俢硕：好的轩老师
Shure: Okay, Teacher Xuan.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia:你达到了
Lucia: You did it.
俢硕：轩老师
Shure: Teacher Xuan.
Katrina:  哈哈哈受不了了她当初也这么叫我
Katrina: Hahaha, can't take it, she used to call me that too.
俢硕：嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe.
Nicous: 哪个前任还是这个
Nicous: Which ex are you talking about, the previous one or this one?
Katrina:  这你就不知道了吧
Katrina: You didn't know that, did you?
Katrina:  昨天晚上新讲的一个
Katrina: It was something new from last night.
Shure: 哦这个啊
Shure: Oh, that one.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha
Nicous: 来对应的了
Nicous: Now it's matching up.
Shure:  就是每天晚上解锁一个新角色
Shure: It's like unlocking a new character every night.
Nicous: 昨天解锁了
Nicous: Unlocked it last night.
Shure:  解锁了就到时候七个葫芦娃
Shure: Once unlocked, there'll be seven in total.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Nicous: 昨天晚上我没来
Nicous: I wasn't there last night.
Shure:  就是白雪公主和七个小矮人
Shure: It's like Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs.
Katrina:  所以
Katrina: So...
Katrina:  当时知道你们都是北邮的我惊呆了
Katrina: I was shocked when I found out you guys were all from BUPT.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 我感觉这辈子
Katrina: I feel like...
Katrina:  跟北邮脱不了关系
Katrina: I can't escape BUPT in this life.
Shure:  其实我们都认识
Shure: Actually, we all know each other.
Shure:  就你说那个人
Shure: That person you mentioned...
Shure:  我们已经查出来是谁了
Shure: We've already figured out who it is.
Katrina:  放屁我才不信你呢
Nicous: 现在那什么颠簸群只要你想查就都能查出来
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Shure:  你先查查
Shure: You check it first.
Shure:  把王爱媛的所有名单调出来跟她意见
Shure: Pull up all of Wang Aiyuan's lists and get her opinion.
俢硕：你快快调一下
Shure: Quickly, pull it up.
Nicous: 调你的 没米
Nicous: You pull it up. There's no rice.
Shure:  没米 跟杨老板申请经费
Shure: No rice? Apply for funds from Jake.
Nicous: 申请经费干这个啊
Nicous: Apply for funds for this?
Katrina:  你是人啊
Katrina: Are you human?
Shure:  我是狗好吧
Shure: I'm a dog, alright?
Shure:  借了个纸你去做狗
Shure: Borrow a piece of paper, you go be a dog.
Shure: 然后呢然后呢
Shure: And then what, then what?
Shure:  快下一步是什么
Shure: What's the next step, quickly?
Katrina:  就上一个板子压他就好了
Katrina: Just put a board on him and it'll be fine.
Katrina:  这就赶走了
Katrina: That'll chase him away.
Katrina: 然后我觉得可以再再夹一层
Katrina: Then I think we can add another layer.
Katrina:  嗯养老
Katrina: Mmm, retirement.
Katrina:  生活
Katrina: Life.
俢硕：就跟养老院似的
Shure: Just like a nursing home.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: ok
Shure: Ok
Shure:  哦这是汉堡的第一层
Shure: Oh, this is the first layer of the burger.
Katrina:  呃
Katrina: Uh
Shure:  他散了
Shure: It's falling apart.
Katrina:  预示着我的爱情
Katrina: Just like my love life.
Katrina:  这样翻哈哈哈
Katrina: Flip it like this, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈好的
Katrina: Haha, okay.
Shure:  好的轩老师哈哈哈
Shure: Okay, Xuan teacher, hahaha.
Katrina:  受不了你了
Katrina: I can't handle you.
Jake: 什么老师
Jake: What teacher?
Katrina:  是他叫我轩老师
Katrina: He calls me Xuan teacher.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Katrina:  他叫我轩老师
Katrina: He calls me Xuan teacher.
Shure: 叫她轩老师
Shure: Calls her Xuan teacher.
Katrina:  他是那种上补习班的小孩
Katrina: He's like a kid in tutoring class.
Katrina:  然后我是旁边老师
Katrina: And I'm the teacher nearby.
Katrina:  他等他妈接他回家吃饭哦
Katrina: He's waiting for his mom to pick him up for dinner, oh.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha.
Shure:  你直接坐一下不就得了
Shure: Just sit down directly, won't you?
Lucia: 不行你要把这袋子拉紧
Lucia: No, you have to pull this bag tight.
Lucia: 哦你这意思我坐在上面拉
Lucia: Oh, you mean I sit on it and pull?
Shure:  对什么叫坐在上面拉
Shure: Yes, what do you mean sit on it and pull?
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Katrina:  好奇怪
Katrina: So weird.
Lucia: 这句话能删掉吗
Lucia: Can we delete this sentence?
Katrina:  AI
Katrina: AI
Jake: 翻译过去
Jake: Translate it over.
Jake: 一没有一点问题
Jake: There's no problem at all.
Shure:  你不坐在上面拉也行
Shure: You don't have to sit on it to pull either.
Katrina: 你做这个吧你来做这个行吗
Katrina: You do this, can you do this?
Katrina: 你做这个行吗
Katrina: Can you do this?
Shure:  你在拉里拉萨
Shure: You're just messing around.
Shure:  你在哪里拉随便你
Shure: You can mess around wherever you want.
Jake: 什么怎怎么翻译这个
Jake: How do you translate this?
Jake: 什么叫坐
Jake: What does sit mean?
Shure:  哈哈我不知道这叫什么
Shure: Haha, I don't know what this is called.
Lucia: 别吧朋友们
Lucia: Come on, friends.
Lucia: 我的一世英名啊
Lucia: My reputation is ruined.
Shure:  sit sit谁
Shure: Sit sit who?
Jake: 谁谁坐
Jake: Who's sitting?
Shure:  他他我我
Shure: Him, him, me, me.
Lucia: 就这个我刚才想把它拉紧然后
Lucia: I was just trying to tighten this up and then...
Shure:  这不压了这个花吗
Shure: Won't that crush the flowers?
Lucia: 不好意思不好意思不好意思
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Katrina:  修硕说我可以
Katrina: Shure said I could.
Jake: 为什么要坐
Jake: Why do you need to sit?
Lucia: 就是坐在上面这样可以压得更紧
Lucia: By sitting on it, it can get tighter.
Jake: 你你你sitting on
Jake: You, you, you sitting on...
Shure:  这样不是
Shure: Isn't it...
Jake: 你sitting on the board是吧
Jake: You sitting on the board, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia:然后我说不行就这个东西要拉紧
Lucia: Then I said no, this thing has to be tightened.
Jake: 哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Shure:  我也可以坐在上面
Shure: I can sit on it too.
Jake: P Puling with you sitting on it right啊OK
Jake: Pulling with you sitting on it, right? Okay.
Shure:  啊你先铺铺点
Shure: Ah, first lay it out.
Shure:  这个还可以给他
Shure: This can still be given to him.
Shure:  那什么给他谐音怎么POL
Shure: How do you say "pull" in a funny way?
Shure:  噗那个噗脸
Shure: Like "puh" face.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我靠哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my, hahaha.
Shure:  你这这中文是互通的有没有
Shure: Your Chinese is really good, right?
Jake: 有有有有
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  你不做完一遍了吗
Shure: Didn't you do it once already?
Shure:  你怎么还需要学啊
Shure: Why do you still need to learn?
Katrina:  就这个啊
Katrina: Just this one.
Shure:  这谁的花
Shure: Whose flowers are these?
Shure:  我就给人家薅了
Shure: I just picked them.
Katrina:  我的全被我剪光了
Katrina: I cut all mine off.
Shure:  这个是谁的
Shure: Whose is this?
Katrina:  我的呀
Katrina: Mine.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 这个真的要弄的很紧吗
Lucia: Does this really need to be very tight?
Jake: 什么时候做狗
Jake: When are we making the dog?
Nicous: 我感觉如果你但凡
Nicous: I feel like if you...
Lucia: 做狗谁不会啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Who can't make a dog, haha.
Nicous: 换成Mac Pro Apple加速特别牛
Nicous: Switch to Mac Pro, Apple speeds up amazingly.
Jake: 把什么
Jake: What?
Nicous: 换成Mac Pro Apple
Nicous: Switch to Mac Pro, Apple.
Jake: 我我有
Jake: I, I have it.
Jake: 那试试
Jake: Let's give it a try.
Nicous: 等这波结束
Nicous: Wait till this wave ends.
Shure:  不是他那个
Shure: No, it's not that.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 是这样干的
Katrina: This is how it's done.
Jake:什么4点的什么
Jake: What about 4 o'clock?
Jake:现在有四点
Jake: It's 4 o'clock now.
Katrina: 问你一个问题
Katrina: Let me ask you a question.
Shure: 你说
Shure: Go ahead.
Katrina: 我想跟你说他不想谈恋爱真是
Katrina: I want to tell you, he doesn't want to date, really.
Lucia:哎那那哦我去
Lucia: Oh, no, I got it.
Lucia:怎么抓在这啊
Lucia: Why is it stuck here?
Shure: 有两种可能
Shure: There are two possibilities.
Shure: 一种的是真的就是现在很忙很烦
Shure: One, he's really busy and stressed right now.
Shure: 然后还有一种可能就是
Shure: And the other possibility is...
Shure: 他没那么喜欢你
Shure: He's just not that into you.
Lucia:我先简单的尝试一下
Lucia: Let me try something simple first.
Katrina: 明白
Katrina: Got it.
Shure: 就这两种可能
Shure: Just those two possibilities.
Shure: 他只要不是现在特别忙那种
Shure: Unless he's extremely busy right now.
Shure: 那就可能是后事当我瞎说了
Shure: Then just consider what I said as nonsense.
Shure: 这仅针对我而言
Shure: This is just my opinion.
Shure: 好了吗
Shure: Are you done?
Shure: 怎么了昨昨天就就那什么去了是吧
Shure: What happened? Yesterday, you went to that place, right?
Shure: oh
Shure: Oh.
Shure: do do do do do do steal
Shure: Do do do do do do steal.
Lucia:这两边不一样紧哎
Lucia: These two sides feel different, huh?
Katrina: 没事然后搞个密封袋把它密封住
Katrina: No worries, then seal it in a ziplock bag.
Shure: 你看看是不是还得坐上
Shure: Check if it needs more time.
Lucia:我这叫从善如流
Lucia: I'm just going with the flow here.
Katrina: 就摘你的花去
Katrina: Just pick your flowers.
Katrina: 我这开的好的都被我摘掉了
Katrina: I plucked all the ones that bloomed well.
Katrina: 哈哈哈这有点丑吧
Katrina: Haha, doesn't it look a bit ugly?
Shure: 我的花
Shure: My flowers.
Katrina: 也行好像
Katrina: It's fine, I guess.
Jake:小手法
Jake: Nice technique.
Shure: 不每片花瓣
Shure: No, each petal...
Shure: 都有他自己的
Shure: Has its own charm.
Shure: 可圈可点之处
Shure: Something to appreciate in its own right.
Shure: 就像谢彬竹一样
Shure: Just like Xie Binzhu.
Lucia:现在差不多了
Lucia: It's almost done now.
Katrina: 又刺激我了吗
Katrina: Are you teasing me again?
Jake:什么梗啊这是
Jake: What's this joke about?
Jake:哈哈哈什么梗啊什么梗啊什么梗
Jake: Hahaha, what's this joke about? What's this joke about?
Katrina: 他这人可贱了
Katrina: He's such a jerk.
Shure: 我就可以
Shure: I can do it.
Jake:说来听听
Jake: Tell us about it.
Shure: 就可以大家都听不懂的状态下
Shure: Just when nobody can understand.
Shure: 然后精准的攻击到他
Shure: Then, precisely attack him.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:可以
Jake: That's good.
Shure: 哇我这些都开了
Shure: Wow, I opened all of these.
Shure: 还有我本来就是开的呀
Shure: And they were already open.
Katrina: 没问题现在已经是金刚之躯了
Katrina: No problem, now I'm as strong as steel.
Katrina: 无所谓我的心跟石头一样
Katrina: Doesn't matter, my heart is like a stone.
Katrina: 你也要耕鸡
Katrina: You also need to toil.
Katrina: 拿你的故事来换
Katrina: Trade your story for it.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 你你顶多做母鸡
Shure: You, you can at most be a hen.
Katrina: 你猜他会放什么歌
Katrina: Guess what song he'll play.
Katrina: 所以快递是他等会寄送过来是吧
Katrina: So, the package will be sent over by him later, right?
Katrina: 不用寄去
Katrina: No need to send it out.
Katrina: 他不是想
Katrina: He doesn't want to...
Lucia:我们的笔到了吗
Lucia: Have our pens arrived?
Katrina: 他不是想去看小狗吗
Katrina: He doesn't want to go see the puppies?
Katrina: 谁带他去看小狗
Katrina: Who's taking him to see the puppies?
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:我没去过
Jake: I haven't been there.
Katrina: 克星
Katrina: Nemesis.
Lucia:我也没见过
Lucia: I haven't seen it either.
Lucia:我也没去过
Lucia: I haven't been there either.
Katrina: 你要不跟他们去看小狗
Katrina: Why don't you go see the puppies with them?
Jake:走带我们去吧
Jake: Let's go, take us there.
Katrina: 就很近很近
Katrina: It's very close, very close.
Katrina: 走溜一圈嘛
Katrina: Let's go for a walk.
Lucia:可以换个鞋吗
Lucia: Can I change my shoes?
Jake:走上楼在抓一个人
Jake: Let's go upstairs and grab someone.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Lucia:不想穿拖鞋去
Lucia: I don't want to wear slippers.
Jake:三楼还有一个薇薇
Jake: There's still a Weiwei on the third floor.
Lucia:可能拖鞋会走着走着掉在路上
Lucia: Maybe the slippers will fall off while walking.
Katrina: 让我穿睡衣就能去
Katrina: Let me wear pajamas to go.
Lucia:这个放哪
Lucia: Where to put this?
Shure: 睡什么
Shure: Sleep what?
Katrina: 我说这能穿睡衣去吗
Katrina: I mean, can I wear pajamas to go?
Lucia:这就放这吧
Lucia: Just put it here.
Lucia:回来还得拼我的这个玩意
Lucia: When we come back, we still have to assemble this thing.
Shure: 从这捡是不可以
Shure: It's not allowed to pick up from here.
Katrina: 为什么你的颗爱心这么大
Katrina: Why is your heart so big?
Katrina: 我去我都是小颗爱心
Katrina: Wow, mine are all small hearts.
Shure: 因为我的爱意更足
Shure: Because my love is more intense.
Shure: 危险
Shure: Dangerous.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 我的荷尔蒙就刺激到它了
Shure: 他们会被压到一起吗
Shure: Will they get crushed together?
Shure: 不会吧
Shure: Probably not.
Katrina: 嗯随便反正自已做自产自销
Katrina: Hmm, whatever, just make and sell by ourselves.
Shure: 剪刀有点不好使
Shure: The scissors are a bit hard to use.
Tasha:比我红的好使
Tasha: Better than my red ones.
Nicous: 这个环干啥的
Nicous: What's this ring for?
Katrina: 不知道啊他叫真就说他真的
Katrina: No idea, he just says it's real.
Katrina: 哈哈哈孔雀
Katrina: Hahaha, peacock.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Nicous: 给我这个确实我就端走
Nicous: Give me this, I'll just take it away.
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: So funny.
Nicous: 不是 我草我的意思是
Nicous: No, I mean, damn, what I mean is...
Nicous: 他说的是狗的一部分
Nicous: He's talking about a part of the dog.
Nicous: 而不是那个人变成狗
Nicous: Not that person turning into a dog.
Nicous: 虽然带上它确实
Nicous: Though putting it on does indeed...
Shure: 这个是她的那个play
Shure: This is her kind of play.
Shure: 我们的轩老师可能好这一口
Shure: Our teacher Xuan might be into this.
Katrina: 轩老师轩老师
Katrina: Teacher Xuan, teacher Xuan.
Katrina: 在给别人做狗呢
Katrina: Becoming a dog for others.
Katrina: 轩老师啊
Katrina: Teacher Xuan, huh?
Shure: 懂了
Shure: Got it.
Nicous: 我来攻击你
Nicous: I'll attack you.
Shure: 轩老师是不是会关注一个公从号
Shure: Is Teacher Xuan following a public account?
Katrina: 不是我觉得他好奇怪
Katrina: No, I think he's really weird.
Katrina: 什么叫那种嗯
Katrina: What do you mean by that, hmm?
Katrina: 一边问你在干嘛
Katrina: On one hand, he asks what you're doing
Katrina: 一边又跟你说自已不想谈恋爱
Katrina: On the other, he says he doesn't want to date
Nicous: 谁 最近的
Nicous: Who? Recently?
Katrina: 一个男的
Katrina: A guy
Katrina: 他也不是纠节好小
Katrina: He's not even that conflicted
Shure: 我怎么能把它
Shure: How can I...
Katrina: 没有就是分手之后这一个暧昧对像
Katrina: No, it's just this one ambiguous relationship after the breakup
Shure: 真的就这一个吗
Shure: Is it really just this one?
Nicous: 我懂了
Nicous: I get it
Katrina: 真就这一个啊
Katrina: It really is just this one
Shure: 你知道为什么吗
Shure: Do you know why?
Shure: 因为他还在跟别人谈
Shure: Because he's still seeing others
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I think so too
Katrina: 可能就是在养鱼吧
Katrina: Maybe he's just keeping his options open
Shure: 有可能
Shure: It's possible
Katrina: 无所谓啊
Katrina: Whatever
Katrina: 然后我就打算
Katrina: So I'm planning
Nicous: 真正的高手是能同时谈他不行
Nicous: Real experts can date multiple people at once, but he can't
Katrina: 嗯吃饭然后第二天就回武汉去
Katrina: Yeah, have dinner, then go back to Wuhan the next day
Katrina: 没有开始呢
Katrina: It hasn't even started yet
Katrina: 都没分手
Katrina: We haven't even broken up
Katrina: 那伤那么重
Katrina: The hurt is so deep
Katrina: 只是觉得他很奇怪
Katrina: I just find him really weird
Katrina: 搞不懂这男的也想什么
Katrina: I don't get what this guy is thinking
Katrina: 为不会是因为她是土像星座啊
Katrina: Could it be because he's an Earth sign?
Nicous: 干什么
Nicous: Doing what?
Shure: 我也是土相
Shure: I'm an Earth sign too
Nicous: 干什么
Nicous: Doing what?
Katrina: 你也是土相
Katrina: You're an Earth sign too
Nicous: 你是水像
Nicous: You're a Water sign
Katrina: 我他
Katrina: I'm...
Katrina: 我是火相
Katrina: I'm a Fire sign
Nicous: 火像是什么座
Nicous: What's a Fire sign?
Shure: 火相是那个
Shure: Fire sign is like...
Katrina: 射手
Katrina: Sagittarius
Shure: 轰轰烈烈
Shure: Passionate and intense
Nicous: 我是我但我一点都不喜欢说实话
Nicous: I am, but I don't like to be honest
Shure: 我是土相
Shure: I'm an Earth sign
Katrina: 我最讨厌
Katrina: I hate...
Katrina: 你们土相
Katrina: You Earth signs
Shure: 怎么啦
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 我们土相怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with us Earth signs?
Katrina: 土相土相
Katrina: Earth signs, Earth signs.
Katrina: 琢磨不明白
Katrina: Hard to figure out.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Shure: 土相就一根筋
Shure: Earth signs are stubborn.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you.
Shure: 他好琢磨的
Shure: They're hard to figure out.
Shure: 土相就是那种
Shure: Earth signs are like...
Nicous: 多去看看抖音
Nicous: Just watch more TikTok.
Shure: 问你在干嘛就代表喜欢你的那种
Shure: If they ask you what you're doing, it means they like you.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Katrina: 呃但是不是
Katrina: Uh, but not really.
Shure: 不
Shure: No.
Katrina: 我是做过攻略的
Katrina: I've researched this.
Shure: 是我说的对吧
Shure: I'm right, aren't I?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Katrina: 但是那个是同时发生的
Katrina: But that happened at the same time.
Jake:一脸蒙逼
Jake: I'm so confused.
Katrina: 你怎么解释呢
Katrina: How do you explain that?
Nicous: 你是什么星座的
Nicous: What's your star sign?
Jake:你猜
Jake: Guess.
Nicous: 我猜啊
Nicous: I guess...
Jake:你们很懂吗
Jake: Do you guys really know?
Katrina: 上网查一下杨婧康
Katrina: Check online for Yang Jingkang.
Jake:你们很懂吗
Jake: Do you really know?
Shure: 我们很懂
Shure: We really know.
Katrina: 很懂
Katrina: Really know.
Shure: 非常懂
Shure: Very well.
Jake:非常懂
Jake: Very well.
Jake:那那那猜一下
Jake: Then, then, then guess.
Katrina: 但
Katrina: But...
Jake:哪里懂得什么
Jake: What do you understand?
Katrina: 就是知道了你座以后才能大概猜一下你性格
Katrina: We can guess your personality after knowing your sign.
Katrina: 倒不能从性格的推出性
Katrina: But we can't deduce your sign from your personality.
Jake:哦不能反对是吧
Jake: Oh, we can't go backwards?
Jake:不能反推是吧对
Jake: Can't go backwards, right.
Katrina: 特别像奶奶啊在这
Katrina: You look just like grandma.
Katrina: 上网百度一下杨靖康吧
Katrina: Check online for Yang Jingkang.
Katrina: 看那guitar上会不会放他的东西啊guitar
Katrina: See if there's anything about him on guitar, guitar.
Nicous: 金牛座
Nicous: Taurus
Shure: 啊 guitar
Shure: Ah, guitar
Jake:guitar可能没放这些东西
Jake: The guitar might not have those things.
Shure: 那上那上另一个HAP上找找去哈哈哈
Shure: Then let's check on another HAP, haha.
Jake:天秤秤
Jake: Libra
Shure: 天秤座也很
Shure: Libras are also very...
Katrina: 前男友天秤座
Katrina: My ex-boyfriend was a Libra.
Shure: 天秤座是什么
Shure: What is Libra?
Katrina: 风相的
Katrina: It's an air sign.
Shure: 他是风相
Shure: He's an air sign?
Shure: 不对啊
Shure: That doesn't seem right.
Katrina: 他不像
Katrina: He doesn't seem like it.
Shure: 所以这个
Shure: So this...
Katrina: 可能我没有看到他的另 一面
Katrina: Maybe I haven't seen his other side.
Katrina: 只看到他工作的一面
Katrina: I've only seen his work side.
Jake:风相应该是什么样
Jake: What should an air sign be like?
Shure: 风相就是
Shure: An air sign is...
Katrina: 蛮疯的
Katrina: Kind of crazy.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Nicous: 向往自由
Nicous: Longing for freedom.
Shure: 对就是每天都是
Shure: Yeah, it's like every day...
Shure: 还想和你谈论宇宙和天空
Shure: They want to talk to you about the universe and the sky.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 或是沙滩里的碎石和人生
Shure: Or the pebbles on the beach and life.
Shure: 哦就是这个样子的一个人
Shure: Oh, that's the kind of person they are.
Shure: 然后呢这是第几层
Shure: So, which layer is this?
Katrina: 整不明白
Katrina: I don't understand.
Katrina: 说什么这个吗嗯
Katrina: Are we talking about this? Hmm.
Shure: 我想快压一次
Shure: I want to press it quickly once.
Katrina: 但是我去这么厚这个能压吗
Katrina: But if I do it so thick, can it be pressed?
Shure: 我就想把它就是这个垮给还原出来
Shure: I just want to restore it to its original state.
Shure: 你懂吗
Shure: You know?
Katrina: 但是应该要把这拔一下
Katrina: But you should pull this out.
Katrina: 反正这太硬了它压不下去
Katrina: Anyway, it's too hard to press down.
Shure: 那你怎么操作
Shure: So how will you do it?
Katrina: 就这样拔吧
Katrina: Just pull it out.
Katrina: 拔然后把它剪短
Katrina: Pull it out and cut it short.
Shure: 那你要把它拔坏了怎么办
Shure: What if you break it?
Katrina: 坏了就坏了呗
Katrina: If it breaks, it breaks.
Shure: 坏了我在这哭
Shure: If it breaks, I'll cry here.
Katrina: 哭吧给你一大嘴巴子
Shure: 哈哈哈你怎么这个样子
Katrina: 这老师可不温柔
Katrina: 但是我妈让我学师范
Katrina: 我说你觉得我能学师范
Katrina: 我打小孩
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Shure: 棍棒底下出孝子
Shure: 严师出高徒
Katrina: 哇这个大花瓣
Shure: 这个话不无道理
Shure: 你给他拆了
Katrina: 不小心掉出一片
Shure: 我就想让他整一个这样子
Katrina: 整一个这个压不了啊
Katrina: 除非你一天到晚用屁股坐着他才能压
Shure: 可以
Katrina: 蛮敬业的哟
Lucia:那咱每次吃饭的时候就坐在上面
Katrina: 能长痔疮
Katrina: You'll get hemorrhoids.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia:这样能让他干的就是
Lucia: This can make him...
Lucia:说更平一点
Lucia: Speak more calmly.
Lucia:只要接触空调就会缩水
Lucia: As long as he touches the air conditioner, he shrinks.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈那应该不至于
Shure: Hahaha, it shouldn't be that bad.
Lucia:哇你的窗帘是吧
Lucia: Wow, are those your curtains?
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 这就是充满爱意和
Shure: They're filled with love and...
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 我没有爱意
Katrina: I don't have any love.
Lucia:这个是雨轩的吗
Lucia: Is this Yuxuan's?
Katrina: 啊这是我的
Katrina: Oh, this is mine.
Katrina: 我买的香薰
Katrina: I bought this fragrance.
Lucia:是那种蜡烛式的吗
Lucia: Is it the candle type?
Katrina: 不是无香的
Katrina: No, it's unscented.
Lucia:好好看等你拆了记得叫我观摩一下
Lucia: It looks great. Let me know when you unbox it, I want to watch.
Katrina: 好好我现在拆
Katrina: Sure, I'll unbox it now.
Lucia:其实我今天打开了这个盒子
Lucia: Actually, I opened the box today.
Lucia:发现里面还有一层盒子
Lucia: And found another box inside.
Lucia:你没有拆过
Lucia: You haven't unboxed it yet.
Lucia:我就决定先留着让你拆
Lucia: I decided to save it for you to open.
Katrina: 我也不知道长啥样呢
Katrina: I don't even know what it looks like.
Jake:走看狗去
Jake: Let's go see the dog.
Jake:可以了吧
Jake: Is it okay now?
Lucia:i'm ready now
Lucia: I'm ready now.
Jake:狗狗
Jake: Doggy.
Alice:噢 小狗
Alice: Oh, puppy.
Lucia:哦好看
Jake:快去
Jake: Go quickly.
Jake:克星呢
Jake: Where's the nemesis?
Katrina: 全体吗
Katrina: Everyone?
Lucia:都可以
Lucia: All is fine.
Katrina: 穿睡衣应该没问题
Katrina: Wearing pajamas should be okay.
Lucia:这是一个自由选择的副本
Lucia: This is a free-choice quest.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Katrina: 跟遛弯一样
Katrina: Just like taking a walk.
Jake:对就是遛弯
Jake: Yes, just like a walk.
Shure: 我我我压花
Shure: I, I, I press flowers.
Shure: 我要一直坐着他
Shure: I want to sit on it all the time.
Katrina: 行啊
Katrina: Sure.
Jake:那个能孵出糖花来
Jake: That can hatch sugar flowers.
Katrina: 冰糖来一颗吗
Katrina: Want a piece of rock candy?
Lucia:这压花的意思其实是压在花上是吧
Lucia: Pressing flowers means pressing on the flowers, right?
Shure: 真是冰糖吗
Shure: Is it really rock candy?
Katrina: 冰糖
Katrina: Rock candy.
Shure: 纯吗这个
Shure: Is it pure?
Tasha:盐呢盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt, where's the salt?
Katrina: 盐做的
Katrina: Made of salt.
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Jake:走走走
Jake: Go, go, go.
Shure: 咿呀
Shure: Yikes.
Jake:走走走
Jake: Go, go, go.
Lucia:好好看
Lucia: Looks really nice.
Katrina: 对我要做一下我的手工任务
Katrina: Yes, I need to do my crafting task.
Katrina: 活儿很重的
Shure: 我怎怎么怎么弄
Shure: How do I, how do I do it?
Shure: 下一步老师老师
Shure: Next step, teacher, teacher.
Katrina: 等一下老师忙副线任务去了
Katrina: Wait a minute, the teacher went to do a side quest.
Katrina: 你可以告诉我怎么做
Katrina: Can you tell me how to do it?
Shure: 然后我自己弄
Shure: Then I'll do it myself.
Tasha:昨天用盐了吗
Tasha: Did you use salt yesterday?
Katrina: 我也不太知道
Katrina: I don't really know.
Tasha:昨天用盐了吗
Tasha: Did you use salt yesterday?
Shure: 昨天好像没怎么用盐
Shure: I don't think we used much salt yesterday.
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Katrina: 唉呀妈呀唉呀妈呀
Katrina: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Shure: 哦如果我想把它压成花的样
Shure: Oh, if I want to press it into a flower shape.
Shure: 我要让他屁股冲上是吗
Shure: Should I have its bottom facing up?
Shure: 嗯然后他的屁股和我的屁股对上
Shure: Hmm, then its bottom should align with mine.
Katrina: 然后这种的话我看人家都是侧着压的
Katrina: I've seen people pressing it sideways.
Katrina: 随便你自己发挥吧
Katrina: Just do whatever you feel like.
Tasha:盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Katrina: 盐
Katrina: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Shure: OK那就这样
Shure: OK, that's it.
Shure: 老师摆的很好
Shure: The teacher arranged it well.
Shure: 然后下一步应该给他盖上盖
Shure: And the next step should be to cover it.
Katrina: 那就
Katrina: Then...
Tasha:不可能呀
Tasha: That's impossible.
Katrina: 压个两层吧
Katrina: Press it into two layers.
Lucia:没桃了还有可能没盐应该不至于吧
Lucia: No peaches left, but running out of salt is unlikely, right?
Shure: 再加一层盐呢
Shure: How about adding another layer of salt?
Tasha:盐呢
Tasha: Where's the salt?
Katrina: 直接给他上两层干燥吧
Katrina: Just dry it in two layers.
Katrina: 感觉这个有点难度呀
Katrina: This feels a bit tricky.
Jake:应该都在这吧
Jake: It should all be here, right?
Lucia:是不是昨天烧烤的时候拿出去用过
Lucia: Did we take it out for the barbecue yesterday?
Lucia:但是那也应该拿回来了吧
Lucia: But it should've been brought back, right?
Katrina: 有点可忘记了
Katrina: Kinda forgot about it.
Katrina: 这中间要不要在加一层
Katrina: Should we add another layer in between?
Lucia:我们有勺了
Lucia: We have a spoon now.
Jake:对买勺了
Jake: Yes, we bought a spoon.
Jake:盐没盐了怎么办
Jake: What if there's no salt left?
Lucia:我先在这组装
Lucia: I'll assemble this first.
Lucia:一会出发了叫我
Lucia: Call me when we're about to leave.
Lucia:说明书上哪了在这
Lucia: Where's the manual? Here it is.
Lucia:啊这玩意装完了我还得给他
Lucia: Ah, after I assemble this, I still need to...
Lucia:到时候再拆一次
Lucia: Disassemble it again later.
Lucia:真麻烦
Lucia: So annoying.
Lucia:咕咕咕咕咕
Lucia: Cluck cluck cluck
Katrina: 我草做错了
Katrina: Damn, I did it wrong.
Lucia:我用一下底下这个东西
Lucia: Let me use this thing underneath.
Katrina: 错了老师
Katrina: It's wrong, teacher.
Katrina: 谁呀给我打电话
Katrina: Who's calling me?
Katrina: 老师喂
Katrina: Hello, teacher.
Katrina: 嗯你哪位
Katrina: Yes, who is this?
Katrina: 不方便拜拜
Katrina: It's not convenient, bye.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Tasha:不要了
Tasha: No need.
Shure: 谁
Shure: Who?
Katrina: 美团
Katrina: Meituan.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 怎么啦
Shure: What's going on?
Katrina: 我不知道他说什么
Katrina: I don't know what he said.
Katrina: 社区客服小盐他问我方不方便
Katrina: The community service called, asking if I'm available.
Shure: 那就是AI的
Shure: That's an AI call.
Katrina: 我说不方便
Katrina: I said I'm not available.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 我觉得我刚看教程说这上面还要粘一层
Katrina: I think the tutorial said to add another layer on top.
Tasha:看狗半个小时
Tasha: Watch the dog for half an hour.
Jake:好半小时绰绰有余
Jake: Half an hour is more than enough.
Tasha:10分钟
Tasha: 10 minutes.
Jake:多久啊一般
Jake: How long usually?
Katrina: 要搞两层卧槽上午做错了
Katrina: Need two layers, damn, I did it wrong this morning.
Jake:狗能看个10分钟吗
Jake: Can the dog watch for 10 minutes?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 上午忘加另一层
Katrina: I forgot to add the other layer this morning.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:走吧出发
Jake: Let's go, let's head out.
Tasha:你不去是吗
Tasha: You're not going, right?
Shure: 我不去
Shure: I'm not going.
Tasha:你能在4:32的时候把火给关掉吗
Tasha: Can you turn off the fire at 4:32?
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 定个闹钟
Katrina: Set an alarm.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 帮我定个4:32闹钟
Shure: Set an alarm for 4:32 for me.
Lucia:哎准备走了好吧
Lucia: Hey, get ready to go, alright?
Jake:走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Lucia:等我回来再接着安排
Lucia: Wait till I get back to continue.
Katrina: 应该是这样
Katrina: It should be like this.
Lucia:呃呃you can get here and
Lucia: Uh, uh, you can get here and...
Lucia:我怎么觉得还有一个2
Lucia: Why do I feel like there's another 2?
Lucia:不管了先这样吧
Lucia: Whatever, let's just go with this.
Katrina: 没关系
Katrina: It's alright.
Katrina: 可以跟你讲了
Katrina: I can tell you now.
Katrina: 为什么就是就是
Katrina: Why it's just, just...
Katrina: 我跟你讲我们是怎么认识的
Katrina: Let me tell you how we met.
Shure: 没人
Shure: Nobody.
Katrina: 感觉特别丢人
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: It's just, just...
Katrina: 当时夏令营保研的时候
Katrina: During the summer camp for grad school.
Katrina: 我不是去面东南吗
Katrina: I went to interview at Southeast.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina: 然后我是早上
Katrina: And then in the morning,
Katrina: 第三批他是早上第一批
Katrina: I was in the third batch, he was in the first.
Katrina: 然后呢他就我就到了很早
Katrina: So, I got there really early.
Katrina: 他就他也到了很早他就戳了一下我
Katrina: 问我就是同学第一批进去要不要带u盘
Katrina: He asked if the first group of students should bring USB drives.
Katrina: 然后我就就那样跟他见第一面
Katrina: That was our first meeting.
Katrina: 但是就是只看他上半张脸
Katrina: But I only saw the upper half of his face.
Katrina: 不知道他长啥样你知道吗
Katrina: You don't know what he looks like, you know?
Katrina: 然后就说了那句话
Katrina: Then he said that thing.
Katrina: 再也没有好的说话
Katrina: Never spoke nicely again.
Katrina: 然后呢后来冬暖结束以后
Katrina: After the winter session ended,
Katrina: 马上又收到了
Katrina: I immediately got
Katrina: 北师的那个录音通知
Katrina: a notification from Beijing Normal University.
Katrina: 然后我就来北京
Katrina: So I came to Beijing.
Katrina: 来北京的时候在吃饭的时候
Katrina: When I arrived in Beijing, during a meal,
Katrina: 他认出我来了
Katrina: he recognized me.
Katrina: 就是我们俩又参加了同一个夏令营
Katrina: We both joined the same summer camp again.
Katrina: 他就问我说
Katrina: He asked me,
Katrina: 同学
Katrina: "Hey, classmate,
Katrina: 你是不是参加过东南大学计算机夏令营
Katrina: did you attend the computer summer camp at Southeast University?"
Katrina: 我说对啊
Katrina: I said, "Yeah."
Katrina: 然后我说你哪位
Katrina: Then I asked, "Who are you?"
Katrina: 然后看一下我就我就认出他俩了
Katrina: And when I looked at him, I recognized him too.
Katrina: 然后这就是我俩认识经过啊
Katrina: And that's how we met.
Katrina: 然后他
Katrina: Then he...
Katrina: 但是那个时候还是有男朋友
Katrina: But at that time, I still had a boyfriend.
Katrina: 后来才分手的
Katrina: We broke up later.
Katrina: 后来分手以后
Katrina: After we broke up...
Katrina: 没有那时候只是当普通朋友啦
Katrina: At that time, we were just normal friends.
Shure: 那时候就已经开始
Shure: It had already started back then.
Katrina: 那时候没啥感觉
Katrina: I didn't feel anything at that time.
Shure: 居心叵测
Shure: Sinister intentions.
Katrina: 那时候就觉得
Katrina: I just felt...
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 你问问你自己是那么想的吗
Shure: Ask yourself if you really thought that.
Katrina: 没有那种感觉
Katrina: I didn't have that feeling.
Katrina: 当时有男朋友谈那么久吗
Katrina: Did I have a boyfriend for that long?
Katrina: 压吧
Katrina: Press it.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 怎么样
Shure: How about it?
Katrina: 这个就直接把它放上去不能让它
Katrina: Just place it directly on the board, don't let it...
Katrina: 然后后来就是嗯
Katrina: And then, um...
Katrina: 我分手那时间9月份还预推免的
Katrina: When I broke up in September, I was still preparing for the exemption exam.
Katrina: 然后就学不进去啊啥的然后
Katrina: I couldn't concentrate on studying, and then...
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then?
Katrina: 我们就就一直聊天哈哈哈
Katrina: We just kept chatting, hahaha.
Shure: 不是你先把这个给我解决吧
Shure: No, solve this for me first.
Katrina: 然后呢然后就直接上木板子就行
Katrina: And then just put it on the wooden board.
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I think so too.
Katrina: 上木板
Katrina: Put it on the wooden board.
Katrina: 上木板都都麻得他那样行弄两根
Katrina: Put it on the wooden board, it will be fine, let's use two pieces.
Katrina: 噫
Katrina: Eww.
Katrina: 那两根呢
Katrina: Where are the two pieces?
Shure: 用两根绑带
Shure: Use two straps.
Shure: 和他玩一些捆绑play是台
Shure: And play some binding games with it.
Katrina: 绑带呢
Katrina: Where are the straps?
Katrina: 啊卧槽
Katrina: Ah, damn.
Katrina: 怎么在地上
Katrina: Why are they on the floor?
Katrina: 有点乱了
Katrina: It's a bit messy.
Shure: 哇好色情这个绑带
Shure: Wow, these straps are so erotic.
Katrina: 人家讲起来很费劲啊
Katrina: It's really exhausting to talk about it.
Katrina: 我就是一直搞不明白这个男的
Katrina: I just can't figure out this guy.
Katrina: 他怎么想的
Katrina: What is he thinking?
Katrina: 因为他之前
Katrina: Because he used to...
Shure: 你可以告诉我他名字吗
Shure: Can you tell me his name?
Katrina: 我觉得是他先
Katrina: I think he should go first.
Shure: 他的名字
Shure: His name.
Katrina: 不行
Katrina: No way.
Shure: 我万一真认识呢
Shure: What if I actually know him?
Shure: 我跟你我认
Shure: I recognize...
Shure: 如果认识这个人
Shure: If I know this person,
Shure: 我就可以跟你进一步分析
Shure: I can give you a more detailed analysis.
Katrina: 真的
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 叫叫叫叫
Katrina: Call, call, call.
Katrina: 应该不认识吧
Katrina: You probably don't know him, right?
Shure:  不认识
Shure: I don't know him.
Katrina: 这个太好了
Katrina: That's great.
Katrina: 嗯，这油好臭
Katrina: Hmm, this oil smells so bad.
Shure: 我们的小小小周
Shure: Our little Zhou.
Katrina: 小周呢就是他先说了一些很越界
Katrina: So, little Zhou was the first to say something inappropriate.
Katrina: 就是包括他还有一些小名啊啥的
Katrina: He even mentioned some nicknames and stuff.
Katrina: 那日分手还包括
Katrina: The day we broke up, he also...
Shure: 小摩尔
Shure: Little Mo'er.
Katrina: 小明
Katrina: Little Ming.
Shure: 管你叫轩老师
Shure: He called you Teacher Xuan.
Katrina: 没有刚开始可是叫轩轩轩轩
Katrina: At first, he called me Xuan, Xuan, Xuan.
Katrina: 天天这样的喊
Katrina: Calling every day like that.
Katrina: 只有我家的长辈才这样喊
Katrina: Only my elders call me that way.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then...
Shure: 见女生面直接叫叠词
Shure: He directly used repeated words when he met girls.
Katrina: 后来聊的比较多
Katrina: Later, we talked more.
Katrina: 就是感觉两个人三观比较相符
Katrina: We felt that our views aligned quite well.
Lucia:好多人他都闻不过来了
Lucia: He couldn't smell a lot of people.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 就聊的特别来包括还有一些很巧很巧的事
Katrina: We had such great conversations, and there were many coincidences.
Katrina: 嗯就我们俩
Katrina: It was just the two of us.
Katrina: 我之前高中听了一个
Katrina: Back in high school, I listened to a...
Katrina: 当时高中听沈雨辰的时候
Katrina: Back in high school, when I listened to Shen Yuchen,
Katrina: 沈雨辰还没火呢
Katrina: Shen Yuchen wasn't famous yet.
Katrina: 还是在抖音上只发自己那个
Katrina: He was just posting his stuff on Douyin.
Katrina: 后来他大学的时候慢慢火了
Katrina: Later, he gradually became famous in college.
Katrina: 然后去参加音乐节唱
Katrina: Then I went to sing at a music festival.
Katrina: 然后当时有一次
Katrina: And at that time, there was this one time...
Katrina: 我前男友不是10天后来找我吗
Katrina: Remember how my ex came to see me after 10 days?
Katrina: 那一次我靠就是明明想通
Katrina: That time, I was like, I had it all figured out...
Katrina: 但是心情还是巨难受
Katrina: But I still felt really awful.
Katrina: 然后我室友都去图书馆了
Katrina: And all my roommates were at the library.
Katrina: 我就特别想找一个人吐槽说话
Katrina: I just really wanted to find someone to vent to and talk.
Katrina: 然后给打电话
Katrina: So I called him.
Katrina: 我打电话
Katrina: I called him...
Katrina: 我发现他铃声就是那一首
Katrina: And I realized his ringtone was that song...
Katrina: 我之前听了很久很久的歌
Katrina: That I had listened to for a really long time.
Katrina: 然后他还跟我说
Katrina: And then he told me...
Katrina: 他的大一就也听了很久很久的事情
Katrina: That he also listened to it a lot during his freshman year.
Katrina: 然后后来包括我们俩那个年度
Katrina: And later, even our yearly playlists had several songs in common.
Katrina: 年度歌单都有好几首重的
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And then there was this thing...
Katrina: 然后还有那个叫
Katrina: And then there was this brand of clothes...
Katrina: 叫叫什么
Katrina: What was it called...
Katrina: 就我之前老想买一个牌子衣服
Katrina: I had always wanted to buy clothes from this brand...
Katrina: 就那holister嘛
Katrina: Hollister, right?
Katrina: 然后身边没有人穿
Katrina: No one around me wore it.
Katrina: 他穿还有一个男生竟然穿
Katrina: He wore it, and another guy even wore it.
Shure: 那是什么衣服
Shure: What brand is that?
Katrina: 就是一个美国的一个快销品牌holister
Katrina: It's this American fast fashion brand, Hollister.
Katrina: 就是比较适合我的身材
Katrina: It suits my body type.
Katrina: 我就经常买他们家的衣服
Katrina: I often buy their clothes.
Katrina: 然后呢反正就聊得特别来吧
Katrina: Anyway, we really hit it off.
Katrina: 然后我们俩
Katrina: And then we...
Katrina: 我当时
Katrina: At that time...
Katrina: 当时后来面北航的时候是9月底
Katrina: When I went to interview at Beihang, it was the end of September.
Katrina: 然后那个时候我们俩已经聊得比较熟了吗一分手
Katrina: By that time, we had gotten pretty close. Right after the breakup...
Katrina: 我靠那次来北京全程接送啊
Katrina: Oh my, he picked me up and dropped me off in Beijing the whole time.
Katrina: 就是当时
Katrina: At that time...
Katrina: 嗯面的心情有点糟糕
Katrina: I was in a pretty bad mood about the interview.
Katrina: 因为全程道歉
Katrina: Because I was apologizing the whole time.
Katrina: 然后他就带我去吃火锅啥的
Katrina: And he took me to eat hotpot and stuff.
Katrina: 就是你知道我前男友
Katrina: You know, my ex...
Katrina: 我跟他出去玩啥的
Katrina: When I went out with him...
Katrina: 是需要我做攻略和安排
Katrina: I had to do all the planning and arrangements.
Katrina: 那吃饭的地你知道吗
Katrina: Even for where to eat, you know?
Katrina: 然后就感觉就被被人照顾那种
Katrina: And I felt like I was being taken care of.
Katrina: 哎反正就是嗯
Katrina: Uh, anyway...
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina: 还有那个什么
Katrina: And then, um...
Katrina: 就那个
Katrina: You know...
Katrina: 就10月底的时候去了一次南昌音乐节
Katrina: At the end of October, I went to the Nanchang Music Festival.
Katrina: 音乐节不看陶喆吗那时候
Katrina: Weren't we going to see David Tao then?
Katrina: 然后呢那一次出去玩的时候
Katrina: So, during that trip...
Katrina: 就跟他去的
Katrina: I went with him.
Katrina: 对跟他去了以后
Katrina: Yeah, after going with him...
Katrina: 我就觉得
Katrina: I felt like...
Katrina: 他对我就是那种
Katrina: He was really...
Katrina: 非常非常照顾的那种感觉
Katrina: Taking great care of me.
Katrina: 然后我就感觉我应该是11月多的时候
Katrina: Then I felt like, around November...
Katrina: 确定自己应该是有点喜欢他
Katrina: I was starting to like him a bit.
Katrina: 但是就是那次之后
Katrina: But after that time...
Katrina: 感觉他有点乎冷乎热的
Katrina: He became a bit hot and cold.
Katrina: 然后就觉得很怪哎
Katrina: And I felt really weird.
Katrina: 影响到我的心情以后
Katrina: It affected my mood afterward.
Katrina: 我后来就有点搓破了
Katrina: After that, I felt a bit broken.
Katrina: 就是我感觉可能
Katrina: I felt like maybe
Katrina: 不该那么早的戳破
Katrina: I shouldn't have broken so early.
Katrina: 后来就变得有点尴尬
Katrina: Then it got kind of awkward.
Katrina: 然后话就越来越少
Katrina: And then we talked less and less.
Katrina: 然后12月的时候我又来北京
Katrina: Then in December, I came to Beijing again.
Katrina: 是因为我很想知道他到底是什么意思
Katrina: Because I really wanted to know what he meant.
Katrina: 但是我没敢问你知道吗
Katrina: But I didn't dare to ask, you know?
Katrina: 然后又来北京的时候
Katrina: And when I came to Beijing again,
Katrina: 他第二天直接不跟我说话了
Katrina: The next day, he just didn't talk to me.
Katrina: 然后哎呦
Katrina: And then, oh well,
Katrina: 我现在觉得他这人好那个呀
Katrina: Now I think he's really something, you know?
Katrina: 然后就
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 就本来是属于那种
Katrina: It used to be like,
Katrina: 几个月每天都在聊天的那种
Katrina: We chatted every day for months.
Katrina: 就那种断崖式暧昧一样你知道吗
Katrina: It was like this sudden drop-off in flirting, you know?
Katrina: 就他那天叫什么突然不找你了
Katrina: Like one day he just stopped reaching out.
Katrina: 那我也不找他了什么的
Katrina: So I stopped reaching out too.
Katrina: 然后就
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 就这样一个多月就没有说话过了
Katrina: We didn't talk for more than a month.
Katrina: 然后本来又是网友就不说话
Katrina: And since we were just online friends, we didn't speak.
Katrina: 就是再也没有联系的那种你知道吗
Katrina: You know, like we completely lost touch.
Katrina: 然后然后就
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 然后后来我还是12月底的时候
Katrina: Later, around the end of December...
Katrina: 我前男友不就考完研了吗
Katrina: My ex-boyfriend finished his exams.
Katrina: 就开始给我发消息那种
Katrina: And then he started messaging me.
Katrina: 然后呢我当时可烦了
Katrina: And I was so annoyed at that time.
Katrina: 然后:然后北邮男的现在我们我们都叫他北邮男的
Katrina: Then, the guy from Beiyou, we all call him Beiyou guy.
Katrina: 一骂就是骂整体北邮男的
Katrina: Whenever we talk about him, we refer to all Beiyou guys.
Katrina: 然后然后他当时
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 他当时也是对我那种忽冷忽热
Katrina: He was hot and cold towards me.
Katrina: 就是你会有的时候会觉得很有希望
Katrina: Sometimes it felt really promising.
Katrina: 就是他跟你说的那些话的时候
Katrina: Like, when he said certain things to you...
Jake:他还知道跑过去
Jake: He even knew to come over.
Katrina: 那有的时候
Katrina: But sometimes...
Katrina: 但是你又能明显的感觉到
Katrina: You could clearly feel...
Katrina: 这三个月内有很大的落差感
Katrina: There was a huge contrast within those three months.
Katrina: 哦然后呢
Katrina: Oh, and then...
Katrina: 嗯我我生日的后一天
Katrina: Um, the day after my birthday...
Katrina: 然后我发现他把我生日给忘了
Katrina: I realized he forgot my birthday.
Katrina: 就12月21那天
Katrina: On December 21st.
Katrina: 然后12月22的时候
Katrina: And then on December 22nd...
Shure: 还有两两分钟
Shure: Two more minutes.
Katrina: 12月12月22的时候我
Katrina: On December 22nd, I...
Shure: 两分钟后叫我
Shure: Call me in two minutes.
Katrina: 12月22的时候我前男友又给我发短信
Katrina: On December 22nd, my ex-boyfriend messaged me again.
Katrina: 我就跟我前男友说他说直接断了
Katrina: I told him to cut it off.
Katrina: 不要再给我发任何短信
Katrina: Don't message me anymore.
Katrina: 就是影响我心情
Katrina: It affects my mood.
Katrina: 然后顺便把北邮男友也给斩了
Katrina: And then I cut off the Beiyou guy too.
Katrina: 就我直接给人家戳明白了
Katrina: I directly told him off.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 我就直接跟他说
Katrina: I told him straight...
Katrina: 他之前的一些言语和行为
Katrina: His previous words and actions...
Katrina: 就是让我会有那种想法
Katrina: Made me think...
Katrina: 就我以为我们俩是在暧昧的
Katrina: That we were in a romantic phase.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 然后啊他那边的意思
Katrina: But then his meaning...
Katrina: 就是普通朋友
Katrina: Was just being friends.
Katrina: 哈哈哈啊
Katrina: Hahaha, right?
Katrina: 是吧然后我说啊
Katrina: So I said...
Katrina: 人家普通朋友这样相处的呀
Katrina: That's how normal friends interact, you know.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Shure: 我懂了
Shure: I get it.
Katrina: 我靠就是高铁上那个时候
Katrina: I mean, like that time on the high-speed train.
Katrina: 嗯我睡着了就靠他肩上
Katrina: Yeah, I fell asleep on his shoulder.
Katrina: 就普通人是这样相处的
Katrina: That's how normal people interact.
Shure: 嗨
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 那时候我以为是暧昧你知道吗
Katrina: At that time, I thought it was something more, you know?
Katrina: 然后就后来
Katrina: And then later...
Katrina: 他后来我觉得怪的一个点就是
Katrina: The weird thing was...
Katrina: 他在中途的时候
Katrina: In the middle of it all...
Katrina: 比如说我说我们计算机来了一个那个
Katrina: Like, I said a new guy joined our computer science class.
Katrina: 那个他学弟还长得挺帅的
Katrina: And he was kinda handsome.
Katrina: 他跟我说那你去加微信啊
Katrina: He told me to add him on WeChat.
Katrina: 然后我想的是
Katrina: And I thought...
Katrina: 暧昧对象
Katrina: If he was interested in me...
Katrina: 就是会让你去加别人的微信吗
Katrina: Would he really tell me to add someone else on WeChat?
Katrina: 就是他一直只把你当普通朋友那种吗
Katrina: Like, was he just seeing me as a normal friend?
Shure: 我感觉
Shure: I feel like...
Katrina: 然
Katrina: Then...
Katrina: 他这人挺怪的你知道吗
Katrina: He was pretty weird, you know?
Katrina: 然后他后来一直没找我以后
Katrina: And then he never contacted me again after that.
Katrina: 我甚至觉得他可能去找前女友了
Katrina: I even thought he might have gone back to his ex.
Katrina: 就是一种第六感你知道吗
Katrina: It's just a gut feeling, you know?
Katrina: 然后然后我就那天跟他斩断
Katrina: So I cut him off that day.
Katrina: 我说以后不要再给我发任何消息
Katrina: I told him never to message me again.
Katrina: 我们俩就这样断了
Katrina: And that was it for us.
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: Then...
Katrina: 然后跨年的时候就跟人家说新年快乐
Katrina: On New Year's Eve, I told him "Happy New Year."
Katrina: 真的真的太丢脸了
Katrina: It was so embarrassing.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hey...
Shure: 你怎么就可一棵树吊死
Shure: Why are you so hung up on one person?
Katrina: 这太丢人了
Katrina: It was so humiliating.
Katrina: 我就因为我就是那种
Katrina: Because I'm just that kind of person...
Katrina: 我是属于那种非常非常典型的火相
Katrina: I'm a typical fire sign.
Katrina: 就是不在乎那种什么面子不面子
Katrina: I don't care about saving face.
Katrina: 我想说就说
Katrina: I say what I want to say.
Katrina: 如果如果我当时憋着更难受的话
Katrina: If holding it in makes me feel worse...
Katrina: 我就会选择说就就是
Katrina: I'd rather just say it.
Katrina: 所有就全靠自己的心情办事
Katrina: I do everything based on my mood.
Katrina: 然后呢后来就偶尔又断断续续聊了
Katrina: Then, we occasionally chatted on and off.
Katrina: 但是后来又觉得
Katrina: But later on, I felt
Katrina: 他有时候就正常的一个话题
Katrina: that sometimes during a normal conversation,
Katrina: 他可能就不接了
Katrina: he might just not respond.
Katrina: 然后又这样断断了以后
Katrina: And after such interruptions,
Katrina: 然后这次这次我是真没想到
Katrina: this time, I really didn't expect
Katrina: 来北京就是我
Katrina: that coming to Beijing, I
Katrina: 我都已经做好心理建设
Katrina: had already prepared myself mentally.
Katrina: 就是就
Katrina: I mean, just
Katrina: 已经掰了呗
Katrina: breaking up, right?
Katrina: 掰了也无所谓啊
Katrina: It's no big deal if we break up.
Katrina: 然后然后又来了一趟北京
Katrina: Then, I went to Beijing again.
Katrina: 他那次脱口秀
Katrina: His stand-up show,
Katrina: 因为当时那个富豪是我俩一起看的
Katrina: we watched it together with that rich guy.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 然后就说约一下线下吧
Katrina: So, we decided to meet offline.
Katrina: 嗯就来了
Katrina: Hmm, so he came.
Katrina: 我当时以为话会很少
Katrina: I thought there would be very little conversation.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 因为他线上就跟我
Katrina: Because he talked very little with me online.
Katrina: 就话特别特别少那种
Katrina: Like, really, really little.
Katrina: 然后呢他线下结果话巨多
Katrina: But offline, he talked a lot.
Katrina: 他一直在跟我说话
Katrina: He kept talking to me.
Katrina: 一直在跟我说
Katrina: Kept talking.
Katrina: 我刚开始觉得有点尴尬
Katrina: At first, I felt a bit awkward.
Katrina: 因为毕竟我这边单方面有点小九九
Katrina: Because, after all, I had some feelings on my side.
Katrina: 然后他就一直在说嗯
Katrina: And he just kept talking, hmm.
Katrina: 他12月那个时候那个项目什么结了
Katrina: That December, he finished a project.
Katrina: 哎呦开第二个什么的
Katrina: Oh, started a second one or something.
Katrina: 然后我就在想难不成真的是
Katrina: Then, I thought, maybe really,
Katrina: 这消失几个月全都在忙工作
Katrina: he disappeared for a few months because he was busy with work.
Katrina: 就是他保北大去了
Katrina: He was applying to Peking University.
Katrina: 他保北大软薇
Katrina: He applied to Peking University for software.
Katrina: 然后呢他没有进组
Katrina: But he didn't get into the program.
Katrina: 但是他有一个自己的那种
Katrina: Instead, he had his own
Katrina: 类似于一种初创公司的那种项目吧
Katrina: kind of a startup project.
Katrina: 就是做高中教辅那一块
Katrina: Involved in high school tutoring.
Katrina: 然后就跟着
Katrina: Then,
Katrina: 然后做一些自媒体的东西
Katrina: he did some social media stuff.
Katrina: 然后然后我觉得他哎真的是
Katrina: And, I thought, wow, really.
Katrina: 真的假的那真的是
Katrina: Really? Is that true?
Katrina: 纯工作吗纯忙去了
Katrina: Just work? Just busy?
Katrina: 然后这就是我来的目的
Katrina: And that's the reason why I came here.
Katrina: 就是我要去问清楚这件事情
Katrina: I need to clarify this matter.
Katrina: 就是啊不是说什么一定要
Katrina: It's not about anything else.
Katrina: 就是表明一下心意吧也不是什么非要在一起的那种
Katrina: Just to express my feelings, it's not like we have to be together.
Katrina: 我觉得一定要问清楚为什么
Katrina: I think it's important to ask why.
Katrina: 当当时他到底是普通朋友
Katrina: At that time, were they just friends?
Katrina: 还是暧昧关系
Katrina: Or was it something more?
Katrina: 然后就断了的时候
Katrina: And when it ended,
Katrina: 就真的只在工作吗
Katrina: was it really just work?
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: Then...
Katrina: 然后那次脱口秀那天回来以后
Katrina: After that comedy show,
Katrina: 就开始找我聊天
Katrina: he started chatting with me.
Katrina: 嗯找我找我说话
Katrina: Yeah, talking to me.
Katrina: 然后最近没
Katrina: And recently,
Katrina: 这两天也有在聊天
Katrina: we've been chatting these days.
Katrina: 哎有的时候呢
Katrina: Sometimes,
Katrina: 就突然跟我说一些爱情观的东西
Katrina: he suddenly talks about his views on love.
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 那有的时候突然又来一句
Katrina: sometimes he suddenly says,
Katrina: 跟我说不想谈恋爱
Katrina: he doesn't want to date.
Katrina: 我老天爷
Katrina: Oh my gosh.
Katrina: 然后当时有跟他讲
Katrina: And then, I told him,
Katrina: 我前男友那个2月份那个破事
Katrina: about my ex-boyfriend and that mess in February.
Katrina: 然后他就说哎呦谁跟你谈恋爱
Katrina: And he said, whoever dates you
Katrina: 真是幸福了
Katrina: is really lucky.
Katrina: 然后然后我在哈哈哈哈什么意思
Katrina: And I was like, hahaha, what does that mean?
Katrina: 然后然后
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 然后刚刚又跟我说谈恋爱太麻烦了
Katrina: he said dating is too troublesome,
Katrina: 还是不谈比较好
Katrina: better not to date.
Katrina: 就觉得自己没有这种经历你知道吗
Katrina: He thinks he hasn't had that kind of experience, you know?
Katrina: 啊然后
Katrina: Ah, then...
Katrina: 这哥们真有意思
Katrina: This guy is really interesting.
Katrina: 把我当狗耍的
Katrina: Treats me like a toy.
Katrina: 在这主要是我
Katrina: The main thing is me.
Shure: 也不是
Shure: That's not it.
Katrina: 我也是那种
Katrina: I mean,
Katrina: 我也不是那种对所有人话都很多的
Katrina: I'm not someone who talks a lot to everyone.
Katrina: 好吧就是虽然说性格比较开朗
Katrina: Well, even though I'm pretty outgoing.
Katrina: 但是也也是那种
Katrina: But it's also like...
Katrina: 也不是说对所有人都很多的那种
Katrina: It's not like that for everyone.
Katrina: 我是这么想的
Katrina: That's what I think.
Jake:喜欢托鞋
Jake: Likes slippers.
Katrina: 然后他刚跟我说哎
Katrina: Then he just told me, "Hey,"
Katrina: 谈恋爱什么太麻烦了哦
Katrina: "Dating is so troublesome."
Katrina: 不想谈恋爱
Katrina: He doesn't want to date.
Katrina: 那你他妈的昨天晚上问我在干嘛
Katrina: Then why the hell did you ask me what I was doing last night?
Katrina: 干嘛昨天晚上不是没回他消息吗
Katrina: Why didn't you reply to my message last night?
Katrina: 上床呆了哦
Katrina: Just lay in bed.
Katrina: 然后他又问我你们在干嘛呀
Katrina: Then he asked me again, "What are you guys doing?"
Katrina: 关你屌事我请问
Katrina: What's it to you?
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina: 然后当时就去琢磨
Katrina: Then I started thinking.
Katrina: 人家MTI跟那个星座去了
Katrina: MTI and that horoscope stuff.
Katrina: 所以我现在是懂懂王
Katrina: So now I'm the know-it-all queen.
Shure: 又觉得自己懂
Shure: You think you know everything.
Katrina: 摩羯
Katrina: Capricorn.
Shure: 不可能懂的
Shure: You can't possibly know everything.
Katrina: 摩羯INTJ
Katrina: Capricorn INTJ.
Katrina: 然后网上测了说我们俩相克
Katrina: Then I did an online test that said we're incompatible.
Katrina: 哈哈哈测塔罗去了
Katrina: Haha, I even did a tarot reading.
Shure: 哎呀乐死我了你可
Shure: Oh my god, you crack me up.
Katrina: 为你我用了所有的办法
Katrina: I tried everything for you.
Katrina: 还挺好看
Katrina: And it actually looks good.
Shure: 哈哈我感觉吧他可能
Shure: Haha, I think he might...
Shure: 因为我知
Shure: Because I know...
Katrina: 你知道你知道那天还很奇怪是什么
Katrina: You know what was weird that day?
Katrina: 就是呃我俩刚认识的时候
Katrina: When we first met,
Katrina: 他他之前前女友是那种高中带上来
Katrina: His ex-girlfriend was someone he dated since high school.
Katrina: 就是人大
Katrina: Like a big deal.
Katrina: 然后他就跟我说
Katrina: Then he told me,
Katrina: 他跟他前女友的矛盾
Katrina: The issues with his ex,
Katrina: 就是属于那种同城都不行
Katrina: Even living in the same city didn't work.
Katrina: 他都接受不了
Katrina: He couldn't handle it.
Katrina: 同城就是要大家在一起谈恋爱那种
Katrina: Living in the same city means you have to be together for the relationship to work.
Katrina: 然后呢那天看完脱口秀
Katrina: Then, after watching the comedy show,
Katrina: 晚上回来跟我说
Katrina: He came back and told me,
Katrina: 对其实我觉得异地恋比不异地好
Katrina: "Actually, I think long-distance is better."
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈对
Shure: Hahahahahaha, right.
Katrina: 这哥们
Katrina: This guy...
Katrina: 就当时
Katrina: At that time...
Katrina: 但是我现在已经就是波澜不惊了
Katrina: But now, I’m already calm and composed.
Katrina: 我不会像以前一样那么那么开心
Katrina: I won't be as happy as I used to be.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Shure: 他已经把把
Shure: He already...
Katrina: 因为我知道他一下这样一下这样
Katrina: Because I know he’s like this one moment, and like that the next.
Katrina: 一下这样
Katrina: Like this...
Katrina: 然后我又无所谓了
Katrina: And then I don't care anymore.
Katrina: 然后我这次过来
Katrina: And this time when I came...
Katrina: 就是已经做好了99%被拒绝的准备
Katrina: I was 99% prepared to be rejected.
Katrina: 因为我想的是什么呢
Katrina: Because what I thought was...
Katrina: 就是你当初那么就是难受的话
Katrina: If you were so upset back then...
Katrina: 就是你一直要猜人家在说什么
Katrina: Always guessing what the other person was saying...
Katrina: 你还不如直接表白然后被拒绝
Katrina: You might as well just confess and get rejected.
Katrina: 然后以后就再也不用跟他联系了
Katrina: Then you wouldn't have to contact him anymore.
Shure: 是的
Shure: That's right.
Katrina: 然后要倒是没想过
Katrina: I never thought about...
Katrina: 如果成功会怎么样
Katrina: What would happen if it worked out.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 就是想的是绝对是那种失败的那种
Katrina: I was sure it would fail.
Katrina: 所以就是拭目以待吧
Katrina: So, just wait and see.
Katrina: 然后我们当时就说
Katrina: At that time we said...
Katrina: 我靠北邮这学校再也不想来了
Katrina: Damn it, I never want to come back to this school.
Katrina: 哈哈哈然后来了这个项目组才发现
Katrina: Hahaha, and then I joined this project and realized...
Katrina: 你们全是北邮的
Katrina: You guys are all from BUPT.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 然后当时就心里小小的破防了一下
Katrina: And then I felt a bit broken inside.
Katrina: 当时觉得
Katrina: At that time, I felt...
Shure: 感觉这两天都能跟
Shure: I feel like these past two days...
Katrina: 因为我一直叫他北邮男
Katrina: Because I always called him the BUPT guy.
Katrina: 北邮男你知道吗
Katrina: BUPT guy, you know?
Katrina: 然后我身边人
Katrina: And the people around me...
Katrina: 所有人都觉得北邮男不是个好东西
Shure: 他妈的
Shure: Damn it.
Shure: 哈哈哈一棍子打死一片是吧
Shure: Hahaha, judging a whole group based on one person, right?
Katrina: 当时真没接触到第二个北邮男
Shure: 好现在你还多接触3个4个北邮男嗯
Shure: Well, now you can meet three or four more BUPT guys.
Katrina: 烤烤烤那个
Katrina: Grilling, grilling...
Katrina: 他这个要烤暖
Katrina: He needs to warm this up.
Katrina: 然后等会要来搞蛋糕
Katrina: And then later we're going to work on the cake.
Shure: 应该 是吧
Shure: Should be, right?
Katrina: 特别难受
Katrina: It's really uncomfortable.
Katrina: 这哥们搞不懂一点
Katrina: This guy doesn't get it at all.
Katrina: 就是感觉几个月没见面以后
Katrina: It feels like we haven't seen each other for months.
Katrina: 我也忙了一点自己的事情就可能
Katrina: I've been busy with my own stuff too, so maybe...
Katrina: 然后那天就是不知道怎么聊到了
Katrina: Then that day, I don't know how we started talking about it.
Katrina: 哦就是刚开始说
Katrina: Oh, at first I said...
Katrina: 聊到我说我几个月都没睡好了一个
Katrina: I haven't slept well for months.
Katrina: 要么就是那个前男友
Katrina: Either it's because of my ex-boyfriend...
Katrina: 当然把我气了一下
Katrina: Of course, he made me so angry.
Katrina: 气的作息不调
Katrina: I was so mad that my sleep schedule got messed up.
Katrina: 作息不调然后每次就到深夜就开始工作完了
Katrina: My sleep schedule got messed up, and then every night I'd start working late.
Katrina: 哈哈哈就习惯这个
Katrina: Haha, I got used to it.
Katrina: 然后我就说他说你前男友什么事
Katrina: Then I said, he asked, "What about your ex-boyfriend?"
Katrina: 我说我草你没看我朋友圈啊
Katrina: I said, "Didn't you see my social media?"
Katrina: 他就是好像就真没看
Katrina: It seemed like he really didn't see it.
Katrina: 然后你给他讲
Katrina: Then you tell him...
Katrina: 讲了以后
Katrina: After you tell him...
Katrina: 就聊到一些这种爱情观的东西
Katrina: We started talking about love perspectives and stuff.
Katrina: 你知道吧
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 然后他当时他就跟我说了一句
Katrina: Then he said something to me.
Katrina: 我觉得你真的很不一样
Katrina: "I think you're really different."
Shure: 哈哈哈哎呦我草
Shure: Haha, oh my god.
Katrina: 哎呀我这什么意思
Katrina: What does that even mean?
Shure: 好拙劣啊我感觉
Shure: It feels so clumsy to me.
Katrina: 哎受不了一点家人们哈哈
Katrina: I can't deal with this at all, guys, haha.
Shure: 因为我知道
Shure: Because I know...
Katrina: 我说我说你说谁不一样
Katrina: I said, "Who do you mean by different?"
Katrina: 你说我吗
Katrina: "Do you mean me?"
Katrina: 哈哈对
Katrina: Haha, yeah.
Katrina: 但是我觉得你跟其他人都不太一样
Katrina: But I think you're different from everyone else too.
Katrina: 嗯是不太一样
Katrina: Yeah, not quite the same.
Katrina: 我说我
Katrina: I said...
Katrina: 身边
Katrina: In my circle...
Katrina: 没有找到第二个跟我想法一样的女生
Katrina: I haven't found another girl who thinks like I do.
Shure: 陈建辉
Shure: Chen Jianhui.
Shure: 断崖式暧昧
Shure: Abrupt ambiguity.
Katrina: 但是我感觉他不是很坚定
Katrina: But I feel like he's not very firm.
Katrina: 一会这样一会那样
Katrina: One moment this, one moment that.
Katrina: 本来就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Katrina: 然后然后就就是
Katrina: And then, and then...
Katrina: 当时就抱着那种必死的决心去见面
Katrina: At that time, I went to meet him with a do-or-die determination.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 就见面了以后
Katrina: So after we met...
Katrina: 就本来想的是表白肯定不成功
Katrina: I thought for sure my confession would fail.
Katrina: 人家那那线上都爱答不理的
Katrina: He was so indifferent online.
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: But then...
Katrina: 然后线下回来以后就对我非常的热情
Katrina: After meeting offline, he was super enthusiastic towards me.
Katrina: 然后问我什么时候下一次吃饭
Katrina: Then he asked when we could have dinner next time.
Shure: 那他
Shure: So he...
Katrina: 然后我就
Katrina: And then I...
Shure: 那你上次才表白
Shure: So you confessed last time...
Shure: 然后他又拒绝了是吗
Shure: And then he rejected you, right?
Katrina: 没我让他别说话
Katrina: No, I told him not to speak.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 傻逼
Shure: Idiot.
Shure: 你神经病吧你
Shure: Are you crazy?
Katrina:  哈哈因为因为他
Katrina: Hahaha, because, because he and my ex...
Katrina: 他跟我前男友都是你知道
Katrina: They both, you know...
Katrina: 他们俩一发任何一点东西
Katrina: Whenever they post anything...
Katrina: 我就心情就会被他们搅一番
Katrina: It messes with my mood.
Katrina: 我就说你别说话
Katrina: So I told him not to speak.
Katrina: 以后再也不要回话了
Katrina: Don't ever respond again.
Katrina: 然后过两天新年快乐
Katrina: Then, a few days later, he said "Happy New Year."
Shure: 哎呦你真
Shure: Oh my, you really...
Shure: 又当又立
Shure: Hypocrite.
Katrina: 无所谓
Katrina: Whatever.
Katrina: 嗯哼
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Katrina: 刚又跟我说不想谈恋爱
Katrina: He just told me he doesn't want to date.
Katrina: 所以我打算不谈哈哈哈
Katrina: So I decided not to date. Hahaha.
Shure: 哎嗨嗨
Shure: Oh, come on.
Katrina: 有病吧这不是
Katrina: Isn't this crazy?
Katrina: 或者他不承认
Katrina: Or he won't admit it.
Katrina: 他现在跟我聊天算什么呢是
Katrina: So what's the point of chatting with me now?
Shure: 哦图一乐呗
Shure: Oh, just for fun.
Katrina: 你知道男生叫什么
Katrina: You know what guys call it?
Katrina: 叫土相加北邮男
Katrina: It's called "earth sign plus northern oil guy."
Katrina: 哈哈哈好吧
Katrina: Hahaha, okay.
Shure: 我感觉
Shure: I feel like...
Katrina: 还有很多人说
Katrina: And a lot of people say...
Katrina: 嗯九十月份时候
Katrina: Yeah, back in September or October...
Katrina: 对我就是那种事事有回应到
Katrina: I always respond to everything.
Katrina: 就是我跟我男朋友前男友在一起5年
Katrina: I was with my boyfriend, ex-boyfriend, for 5 years.
Katrina: 都就是完全超过那个程度
Katrina: We were really close, beyond that level.
Katrina: 就那种细致程度
Katrina: That kind of detailed level.
Katrina: 帮我俩出去吃饭
Katrina: Helping each other out with meals.
Katrina: 嗯当然穿的VANS磨脚了
Katrina: Yeah, and when my VANS shoes hurt my feet.
Katrina: 因为我点菜的时候
Katrina: Because when I was ordering food...
Katrina: 他就去帮我找创可贴了
Katrina: He went to get me a band-aid.
Katrina: 那种就你不用跟他说
Katrina: That kind of stuff, you know?
Katrina: 你稍微可能几个小时说一句话
Katrina: You don't even need to tell him.
Katrina: 几个小时前说一句话他可能就记住了
Katrina: You say something hours ago, he remembers.
Katrina: 嗯但我听他也给我讲
Katrina: Yeah, but I heard him tell me...
Katrina: 然后包括我们俩出去玩什么
Katrina: About us going out and stuff...
Katrina: 都是他安排
Katrina: He always planned it.
Katrina: 他就那天玩完了
Katrina: After we had fun that day...
Katrina: 然后在出租车上有点累两个人没说话
Katrina: We were tired in the taxi, didn't talk much.
Katrina: 人说哎火锅消化了好想来一碗
Katrina: Someone said, "Hotpot digested, want a bowl of..."
Katrina: 他是厦门人
Katrina: He's from Xiamen.
Katrina: 然后我说好想来一碗四果汤
Katrina: And I said, "I want a bowl of Siguo Tang."
Katrina: 就他我不是去厦门玩了
Katrina: Like when I was in Xiamen...
Katrina: 四果汤那边的一个那清补凉那种东西
Katrina: Siguo Tang is like Qingbuliang there.
Katrina: 然后呢他也没怎么说话
Katrina: And he didn't say much...
Katrina: 就感觉他话好像不是特别多那种
Katrina: Felt like he wasn't very talkative.
Katrina: 然后我再一回头他已经帮我点外卖了
Katrina: Then I turned around, and he'd already ordered delivery.
Katrina: 就这种你知道吗
Katrina: That kind of thing, you know?
Katrina: 然后我就特别吃这种
Katrina: And I really like that.
Katrina: 我就觉得
Katrina: I just think...
Katrina: 哎呀人家把你那个话什么都放心里
Katrina: Wow, he keeps everything you say in mind.
Shure: 好想拿你哎
Shure: Really want to keep you, huh?
Katrina: 嗯是可能这么讲这需要多谈几段
Katrina: Hmm, maybe it means we need to date a few times more.
Katrina: 然后我觉得他刚和
Katrina: And then I think he just...
Katrina: 应该是对我有一点喜欢
Katrina: He probably liked me a bit.
Katrina: 但是我不知道他为什么后来就这样
Katrina: But I don't know why things ended up like this.
Shure: 不他我感觉就是被
Shure: 你某一个特质就是吸引了，但是
Shure: And you have a certain quality...
Shure: 就是至于到那种谈恋爱那个地步
Shure: That makes you reach that level of dating.
Shure: 可能我不知道有没有
Shure: Maybe, I don't know if there is.
Katrina: 搞不懂所以我要问清楚吗
Katrina: I don't get it, so should I ask clearly?
Shure: 因为我我们21号办这个活动
Shure: Because we have this event on the 21st.
Katrina: 22号什么时候散
Katrina: When does it end on the 22nd?
Katrina: 因为我要想要买票嘛
Katrina: Because I want to buy tickets.
Katrina: 不知道 22号还要在这呆一整天嘛
Katrina: I don't know if I'll have to stay here the whole day on the 22nd.
Shure: 不要了
Shure: No need.
Katrina: 白天
Katrina: During the day?
Shure: 21号收尾工作之后你就可以走了啊
Shure: After the wrap-up on the 21st, you can leave.
Katrina: 他说22号 22号
Katrina: He said the 22nd, the 22nd.
Katrina: 昨天问他干嘛
Katrina: Why did I ask him yesterday?
Katrina: 他说摸鱼
Katrina: He said he was slacking off.
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, yeah.
Shure: 对对对周一
Shure: Yes, yes, Monday.
Katrina: 昨天不是亏死了一圈吗
Katrina: Didn't we lose a lot yesterday?
Shure: 22号应该就是收拾完然后就走
Shure: On the 22nd, we should just tidy up and then leave.
Katrina: 嗯 22号收拾一下
Katrina: Yeah, tidy up on the 22nd.
Katrina: 所以我就觉得
Katrina: So, I think...
Katrina: 到底是22号晚上约他吃饭呢
Katrina: Should I invite him to dinner on the night of the 22nd
Katrina: 还是23号晚上约他
Katrina: or on the night of the 23rd?
Katrina: 约一下然后第二天白天可以走
Katrina: Invite him, then leave the next morning.
Katrina: 就是觉得百分百被拒绝
Katrina: I just feel like I'm definitely going to be rejected.
Katrina: 然后就结果那玩意学校的事也很多
Katrina: And then there's a lot of stuff at school too.
Katrina: 分析分析呗哥
Katrina: Analyze it for me, bro.
Shure: 反正我这几年不像吗
Shure: Well, haven't I been like this for years?
Katrina: 不是土相的吗哈哈哈
Katrina: Aren't you an Earth sign? Haha.
Shure: 没闲着
Shure: Never idle.
Shure: 经常会有那种断崖式什么
Shure: Often there's that kind of cliff-like...
Shure: 就断崖式暧昧
Shure: Just cliff-like ambiguity.
Shure: 这种
Shure: This kind.
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Shure: 就是跟一个女生暧昧
Shure: Just being ambiguous with a girl.
Shure: 突然就
Shure: Then suddenly...
Katrina: 谁啊
Katrina: Who?
Shure: 我
Shure: Me.
Katrina: 你啊
Katrina: You?
Katrina: 你们同学是为什么呢
Katrina: Why are your classmates like this?
Shure: 也不是我就感觉双方都是这个样子
Shure: It's not that, I just feel like both sides are like this.
Shure: 就有的时候可能是我热脸贴冷屁股
Shure: Sometimes, it's like I'm warm and they're cold.
Shure: 而且我有个特别傻逼的一点
Shure: Plus, I have this really stupid thing...
Shure: 就是我原来那个
Shure: So, my original...
Shure: 尤其大一的那时候
Shure: Especially during my freshman year...
Shure: 大一大二的时候
Shure: Freshman and sophomore years...
Shure: 就老控制不好自己酒量
Shure: I just couldn't control my drinking...
Shure: 然后有的时候就是
Shure: And sometimes...
Shure: 跟室友喝着喝着
Shure: When drinking with my roommates...
Shure: 喝多了
Shure: I'd get drunk...
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm...
Shure: 然后我就会
Shure: And then I would...
Katrina: 给人打电话
Katrina: Call people...
Shure: 也不是打电话
Shure: Not really call...
Shure: 就发一堆奇奇怪怪的语音
Shure: Just send a bunch of weird voice messages...
Shure: 我靠然后
Shure: Damn, and then...
Shure: 然后就基本这种情况下
Shure: In those situations...
Shure: 第二天就再也不想见了
Shure: The next day, I just never wanted to see them again...
Shure: 但是神奇的是
Shure: But surprisingly...
Shure: 这种情况之后都没有删这些人
Shure: I never deleted those people after that...
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha...
Katrina: 你也蛮抽象的
Katrina: You're pretty abstract too...
Katrina: 然后第二天你们还会聊天吗
Katrina: And the next day, would you still chat?
Shure: 不会那个我那个有
Shure: No, there's this one person I used to chat with a lot...
Shure: 之前有一个就是一直聊的很好的吧
Shure: We were pretty close...
Shure: 算是
Shure: Sort of...
Shure: 然后就是开学之后就是想约他再见面
Shure: And then after the new semester started, I wanted to meet up with him again...
Shure: 然后就一直没约到
Shure: But it just never happened...
Shure: 就是暑假之前跟他认识
Shure: We met before summer vacation...
Katrina: 一个学校的吗
Katrina: Same school?
Shure: 对一个学校的
Shure: Yeah, same school...
Katrina: 他妈一个学校的都进来这么慢
Katrina: Damn, both at the same school and still so slow...
Katrina: 要我直接
Katrina: If it were me...
Katrina: 哎口嗨
Katrina: Oh, just talking big...
Katrina: 哈哈你三个月都没确认关系呢
Katrina: Haha, you didn't even confirm the relationship in three months...
Katrina: 我还在这口嗨
Katrina: And I'm just here talking big...
Shure: 差不多都都一样嗨
Shure: Yeah, it's kinda the same for everyone...
Katrina: 主要武汉理工真没看到喜欢的
Katrina: Mainly, at Wuhan University of Technology, I haven't seen anyone I like...
Katrina: 好奇怪啊
Katrina: It's so weird...
Katrina: 看了四年没看到
Katrina: Haven't seen anyone in four years...
Shure: 可能是要穿的比较
Shure: Maybe it's about how they dress...
Shure: 不对那你有各种艺术团什么的
Shure: No, but there are all kinds of art groups and stuff...
Katrina: 嗯有啊
Katrina: Hmm, yeah...
Shure: 反正我就每几乎每一个时间段都会
Shure: Anyway, I almost always find someone like this at every time.
Shure: 找一个类似于这样的
Shure: Find someone similar to this.
Katrina: 关系
Katrina: Relationship.
Shure: 暧昧对象的关系吧算是对
Shure: It's kind of like an ambiguous relationship, right?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Oh.
Shure: 我甚至有更离谱的
Shure: I even have more outrageous stories.
Shure: 比如说那种就是那种两个人都
Shure: Like, for example, two people have kissed and...
Shure: 亲过了然后都那种谈的
Shure: they've talked about it, you know?
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know what I mean?
Katrina: 我知道当时我们班嗯有个男生
Katrina: I know, back then in our class, there was this guy...
Katrina: 当时我们就出来吃饭
Katrina: We went out for dinner...
Katrina: 就是上个月吧
Katrina: Just last month.
Katrina: 然后他跟我讲的也是你这样子
Katrina: And he told me something similar.
Katrina: 那男的说 我靠
Katrina: The guy said, "Damn...
Katrina: 为什么我们都亲过了
Katrina: Why did we kiss if...
Katrina: 然后说好什么
Katrina: we agreed on something...
Katrina: 说在一起来着
Katrina: to be together?"
Katrina: 然后那女的把我鸽了
Katrina: Then she ghosted me.
Katrina: 你说我就不明白为
Katrina: I just don't understand why...
Katrina: 什么不喜欢还得亲上了呢
Katrina: if she didn't like him, she kissed him anyway.
Katrina: 感觉可怜你知道吗
Katrina: It's kinda pitiful, you know?
Shure: 七万
Shure: Seven thousand.
Katrina: 他还跟我说你看小峰他们至少还牵手了
Katrina: He even told me, "Look at Nicous and them, at least they held hands."
Katrina: 你这心里在这迭代半天手都没牵过
Katrina: You are here, thinking for so long, and haven't even held hands.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 就别骂了
Katrina: Don't scold me.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 但是我觉得你过了亲密关系以后
Katrina: But I feel like after you get into an intimate relationship...
Katrina: 会有介断的感觉
Katrina: there will be a sense of interruption.
Katrina: 你说不适应吗就是两个人
Katrina: Don't you feel uncomfortable, like the two people...
Shure: 这就是换了不同人来了
Shure: It's just replaced by different people.
Katrina: 后来就有新的人
Katrina: Then there are new people.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 我靠 桃花运不错啊
Katrina: Damn, your luck with love is pretty good.
Shure: 也不算就是能说上话的
Shure: Not really, just people I can talk to...
Shure: 然后两个人一直聊的那种
Shure: and we keep chatting.
Katrina: 主要我感觉他不会聊天几句话能把人聊死
Katrina: Mainly, I feel like he can't chat. He can kill the conversation in a few sentences.
Shure: 也不是哎
Shure: That's not true.
Shure: 我之前
Shure: Before, I...
Shure: 去那个北京
Shure: Going to Beijing.
Shure: 有一个特别有名的地方叫四顾
Shure: There's a really famous place called Sigu.
Shure: 就是
Shure: It's like...
Shure: 类似于酒吧吧
Shure: It's kind of like a bar.
Shure: 就是一个lifehouse的酒吧
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Shure: 我之前去那个场地演过5次还是6次
Shure: I've performed at that venue like 5 or 6 times.
Shure: 就每次啥身边的姑娘都不是一个人
Shure: Each time, the girl next to me was different.
Katrina: 你 你现在的女朋友知道吗
Katrina: Does your current girlfriend know?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Uh...
Katrina: 你女朋友知道吗
Katrina: Does she know?
Shure: 啊 知道呀
Shure: Yeah, she knows.
Shure: 因为有有的时候就她啊
Shure: Because sometimes, it was her.
Shure: 也不能说每次吧
Shure: Not every time, though.
Shure: 就是反正
Shure: Basically...
Shure: 没没没基本没重样
Shure: There were rarely repeats.
Shure: 每次那个那个那个
Shure: Each time, the manager would look at me...
Shure: 经济人看我都
Shure: with that expression.
Shure: 对这个表情
Shure: You know, haha.
Shure: 知道吧哈哈哈
Shure: You get it, haha.
Katrina: 厉害厉害
Katrina: Impressive, impressive.
Shure: 一个两个
Shure: One or two...
Katrina: 要是当时同时暧昧多个
Katrina: What if you were flirting with multiple people at the same time?
Shure: 那我不会同时就是暧昧多个人
Shure: I wouldn't flirt with multiple people at once.
Katrina: 就是现在有有包括那个
Katrina: You know, like now, including that guy...
Katrina: 就是我要求过来的那个男生
Katrina: the one I asked to come over.
Katrina: 他就是也是保研认识的
Katrina: We met through a graduate school recommendation.
Katrina: 当时保研路上网友
Katrina: He was an online friend.
Katrina: 就网友然后也是
Katrina: And then we...
Katrina: 线下见面了以后他
Katrina: met offline.
Katrina: 他来武汉旅游
Katrina: He came to Wuhan for a trip.
Katrina: 就找我线下玩了一次以后
Katrina: We hung out once.
Katrina: 开始每天找我聊天
Katrina: After that, he started chatting with me every day.
Katrina: 但是我当是对他
Katrina: But at that time, I...
Shure: 就没什么感觉也不喜欢他
Shure: You didn't have any feelings for him.
Katrina: 就是那种你第一眼没有感觉
Katrina: Like, if you don't feel something at first sight...
Katrina: 之后就不会有感觉了
Katrina: you'll never feel it.
Shure: 确实
Shure: True.
Katrina: 只能日久生情的那种
Katrina: Only if you spend a long time together.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 就是之前我
Katrina: Before, my...
Katrina: 嗓子哑了过
Katrina: My voice went hoarse.
Katrina: 我都不知道我嗓子怎么哑了
Katrina: I had no idea why.
Katrina: 你知道不我都没感觉
Katrina: Did you know? I didn't even feel it.
Katrina: 我那天晚上难受我就找我闺蜜睡觉
Katrina: That night, I felt so bad, I went to sleep at my best friend's place.
Katrina: 我跟她讲了一晚上话
Katrina: We talked all night.
Katrina: 我跟她讲了一晚上我前男友坏话
Katrina: I spent the whole night badmouthing my ex.
Katrina: 第二天嗓子就哑了
Katrina: The next day, my voice was gone.
Katrina: 就是那种就完全说不出话那种
Katrina: I mean, completely gone.
Katrina: 就就持续了7天
Katrina: It lasted for seven days.
Katrina: 而且而且特别搞笑
Katrina: And it was so funny.
Katrina: 我跟你说我过我好不容易好了两天
Katrina: I finally got better after two days.
Katrina: 好了两天以后那天我看到有一个女生
Katrina: After those two days, I saw a girl...
Katrina: 手里拿了郁金香我就跟我宿友说
Katrina: Holding a tulip, I told my roommate,
Katrina: 你看我那就是我跟我前男友说
Katrina: "Look, I told my ex-boyfriend
Katrina: 很想养这种花
Katrina: that I really wanted to grow these flowers."
Katrina: 刚把我前男友几个字说完
Katrina: Just as I finished saying "my ex-boyfriend,"
Katrina: 我嗓子又哑了半天
Katrina: my throat went hoarse for a moment.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈有毒
Shure: Hahaha, that's hilarious.
Katrina: 笑死了
Katrina: I laughed so hard.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina: 然后我现在心态就比较轻松
Katrina: Now I feel more relaxed.
Katrina: 嗨
Katrina: Hi.
Katrina: 然后我就我就我就发现
Katrina: I realized that
Katrina: 比较轻松的时候
Katrina: when you're relaxed,
Katrina: 你就跟他说话就不用考虑那么多
Katrina: you don't have to think so much when talking to him.
Katrina: 不用考虑那么多
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 你就他说哎呀
Katrina: You just tell him, "Oh well,"
Katrina: 他不想谈恋爱
Katrina: "He doesn't want to date."
Katrina: 我就说那行不谈不谈
Katrina: I said, "Alright, no dating then."
Katrina: 我说我长这么漂亮我肯定要谈
Katrina: I said, "I'm so pretty, I definitely want to date."
Katrina: 然后他说好啊谈好
Katrina: Then he said, "Okay, fine, let's date."
Katrina: 他说谈帅的吃点好的
Katrina: He said, "Date handsome guys and eat well."
Katrina: 然后我就没有回他了
Katrina: Then I just didn't reply.
Katrina: 是吧 这这这回什么呀这是
Katrina: Right? What was I supposed to say to that?
Shure: 谁知道不是我跟
Shure: Who knows, it wasn’t me.
Shure: 你讲就是女生
Shure: I’m saying, it’s a girl.
Shure: 比如说跟我讲这种
Shure: For example, when you tell me this kind of thing
Shure: 我会虽然表面很那什么呵
Shure: I might look calm on the surface but
Shure: 那你谈去吧
Shure: You go talk to them
Shure: 然后就这种
Shure: And then this happens
Shure: 但是内心其实是吃醋的你知道吗
Shure: But inside, I'm actually jealous, you know?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Katrina: 当时我跟他
Katrina: When I was with him
Katrina: 断崖断暧昧结束以后呢
Katrina: After the ambiguous phase ended
Katrina: 我就呢我去看星座
Katrina: I started looking at horoscopes
Katrina: 然后呢我就发现
Katrina: And then I found out
Katrina: 他们说土相
Katrina: They say Earth signs
Katrina: 就是很不一样
Katrina: Are very different
Katrina: 就老喜欢说反话什么的
Katrina: They always like to say the opposite of what they mean
Shure: 他土相是不会把自己的
Shure: Earth signs won't show their true feelings
Katrina: 对他不说
Katrina: Yes, they don't say it
Shure: 真实特别真实的想法给表现出来
Shure: They don't express their real, deep thoughts
Katrina: 他能表现出吃醋就是说
Katrina: If he shows jealousy, it's like saying
Katrina: 哎你去那你去加呀
Katrina: Hey, you go add them
Katrina: 我说我草我哪有说这话
Katrina: And I'm like, what, did I really say that?
Katrina: 我想难道他那时候是吃醋那个时候
Katrina: I wondered if he was jealous at that time
Shure: 是的真的有可能就是这个样子
Shure: Yes, it's very possible
Katrina: 然后我当时有问他
Katrina: Then I asked him
Katrina: 为什么你老让我加别人的微信呀
Katrina: Why do you always ask me to add other people on WeChat?
Katrina: 他说他也没有权利去限制我
Katrina: He said he didn't have the right to limit me
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Right
Shure: 我我也会这么想想
Shure: I would think the same
Katrina: 我也不是完全希望你去加当时
Katrina: It's not like I completely wanted you to add them
Shure: 确实
Shure: Exactly
Katrina: 他是这么说的
Katrina: That's what he said
Shure: 那就对了
Shure: That's right
Shure: 没错而且不要老看什么星座什么MBT啊
Shure: And don't always look at horoscopes or MBTI
Shure: 就这种我特不爱算算
Shure: I really don't like calculating these things
Shure: 就感觉
Shure: It feels like
Katrina: 当你走投无路你就相信
Katrina: When you're desperate, you believe in them
Katrina: 哈哈你
Katrina: Haha, you
Shure: 不不不你走投无路你信你自己
Shure: No, no, no, when you're desperate, believe in yourself
图纱:咱这也可以不准去世界
Tasha: We can't predict the world either
Shure: 你信你不要不要你不是你
Shure: Believe in yourself, don't, don't, you're not
Shure:  比如说你算什么什么不好
Shure: For example, if you calculate something bad
Shure: 然后你心里就会一直犯嘀咕这个
Shure: And then you’ll keep doubting yourself about this.
Shure: 就还还会就给自己图增
Shure: And then you'll keep adding more to your worries.
Katrina: 你别说当时
Katrina: Don't even mention at that time...
Shure: 一堆的负面情绪嘛哈哈哈嗯
Shure: Just a bunch of negative emotions, haha, yeah.
Katrina: 我给你说当时
Katrina: Let me tell you, at that time...
Katrina: 就是我俩断崖式那时候
Katrina: It was like we hit rock bottom.
Katrina: 然后那一会去占卜那个
Katrina: And then, we went to get a fortune telling.
Katrina: 占
Katrina: Got it?
Katrina: 就是搞那个因为
Katrina: We did it because...
Katrina: 本来也闲吗保研之后
Katrina: We were free after grad school.
Katrina: 然后就说
Katrina: And so...
Katrina: 那种暧昧像
Katrina: That kind of ambiguous feeling...
Katrina: 我靠测出来都是说
Katrina: I mean, the readings said...
Katrina: 我们那种比较非常合适
Katrina: We were quite compatible.
Katrina: 但是又是那种巨恐怖的关系
Katrina: But it was also a terrifying relationship.
Katrina: 就是绝对是game over的那种
Katrina: Like, it was definitely game over.
Katrina: 然后后来连连去看他测三四次
Katrina: Then later, we kept going back three or four times.
Katrina: 都是这种
Katrina: It was always the same.
Katrina: 因为那个不准我很信
Katrina: Because it wasn't accurate, but I trusted it.
Katrina: 就是他每个月给我测都很准
Katrina: Every month, the readings were accurate for me.
Katrina: 我有一个月巨倒霉
Katrina: One month, I was super unlucky.
Katrina: 就是测出来就比较凶
Katrina: The reading said it would be bad.
Katrina: 然后但是我基本上都是比较顺的那种
Katrina: But usually, my readings were pretty smooth.
Katrina: 然后然后呢
Katrina: And then...
Katrina: 就然后我就不测了然后就自已玩
Katrina: I stopped getting readings and just did my own thing.
Katrina: 然后最近它又老出这种
Katrina: But recently, it keeps showing...
Katrina: 暧昧相感情相
Katrina: Ambiguous feelings, emotions.
Katrina: 然后测我四月份
Katrina: So, in April...
Katrina: 和他取得联系的时候又测了一下
Katrina: When I contacted him again, I did another reading.
Katrina: 那现在测出来就还好
Katrina: And now the reading is okay.
Katrina: 昨天晚上又测了一挂
Katrina: Last night, I did another reading.
Shure: 你闲的
Shure: You have too much free time.